the church of what's happening now is
presented by onit
this show is brought to you by blue
apron for less than ten dollars per
person per meal blue apron delivers
seasonal recipes along with the
pre-proportioned ingredients to make
delicious home-cooked meals
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blueapron.com
joey that's blueapron.com
joey
show is also brought to you by lyft
drive with lyft it's the ride sharing
app that lets you be your own boss pick
your own hours and earn up to 1500 bucks
a week driving your own car
sign up today at lyft.com joey and right
now if you complete 100 rides in 30 days
you're gonna get an extra five hundred
dollar driving bonus go to lyft.com joey
oh [ __ ]
you know what time it is when bob
marley's in the neighborhood
it's the church of what's happening now
lee syed eleanor kerrigan yes and your
uncle joey diaz kick it lee
i want the speakers to blow up lee i
want the computer to blow up
i want you to press [ __ ]
death
that's as loud as it goes
oh wow
oh [ __ ]
here you go [ __ ]
so we're gonna
oh [ __ ] it's thursday
smoother than the [ __ ] that bob
marley what's happening you sexy
[ __ ]
welcome to the podcast kingdom of death
lisa ayat my favorite jewish person in
the world hello shalom eleanor kerrigan
and your uncle joey d is here on a
beautiful wednesday night in los angeles
i don't know kerrigan what's happening
nothing i'm excited to be here sexy bob
marley bringing us in we were talking
about [ __ ] uh affairs like having
like
you know we're talking about the
difference of walking into a closet and
bumping into a victim
and her licking your nut sack and you're
going one way and her going the other
and then you refuse her on facebook
because she didn't even make the you
know you're professionals you just yeah
and then you have the people who start a
completely different family and then at
the end you know we're talking about how
the
you're never going to leave your wife
right now yeah
and women will they'll look in the face
and i'm telling you because i had a
friend like that he was going to leave
his wife
he's going to leave his wife he's going
to leave his wife you know what happened
they got drunk and they killed a couple
together oh jesus she didn't go to jail
he went to jail and guess what when she
got home she found that she was pregnant
so she had to move to florida he's
living around here out of jail riding a
bicycle
because they won't give him a license i
was gonna just took his license oh they
took his license for this life and the
next one he can't even drive a chariot
if he comes back chinese they won't even
let him drive a rickshaw he's on
bicycles for the rest of his life
i'm [ __ ] believable all for killing a
family you lose your license
uh for life two people thank you two
people in the car when you're drunk
oh he i said i mean yeah drinking and
driving got you gotcha
and she used to tell me stories that
they'd be [ __ ] and the ex-wife would
be banging on the door let me in i know
she's in there you [ __ ] i have
two girls with you and he would keep
[ __ ] and drilling her and she oh
and she loved it they love it they love
it why do people love the excitement of
the the the secret the big secret i
don't get it i don't know
i know the last five years of my cocaine
use it was basically
i got high from going to get it
right
i get it yeah that's true like i was one
of the last people to get a medical
marijuana license i didn't believe in it
i'm still old school i like going to the
guy's house and driving home with it in
the trunk
and nobody knows nothing you know
i always like that that's the intrigue
of it it makes you feel dirty yeah
that's part of the whole thing going
into a room when you're a regular
[ __ ] nerd
if you buy weed and you walk into the
room and sons of anarchy in there you're
at the right place you're a nerd you
leave they're like this is okay see
that's why i like weed stores is because
i never once i never once bought weed
from a dealer it scares the [ __ ] out i
know i'm gonna go to the undercover cop
i'm gonna get stuff laced with something
so i like paranoid yeah yeah i'm that's
welcome to my life it's more fun that
way well that's how you know i i came up
getting out of a car in harlem first of
all you got to go to heart
we got weed in jersey but first of all
you gotta go to harlem
and then once you got the [ __ ] harlem
you had to park in front of you know
down the block do it right like i go to
the weed store here and there's people
double parked in front i always ask them
roll down the window would you park in
front of your drug dealers no don't
bring attention to this place yeah go 50
yards down you [ __ ] amateur i agree
with hazards on in front of the [ __ ]
weed store go down the corner stupid
let's just wear a sign it was all part
of it and i'd have eleanor in the car
waiting for me
and i'd walk into a pool hall you
pressed the buzzer
and you walked in the guy had 10
different types of weed on the table and
you took two or three bags and you got
in your car
now
we're professionals amateurs go right
back over the bridge not us we're on the
west side highway we get off on like
57th street and we stay on 12th avenue
and we stop we get a hot dog while we
eat the hot dog you roll the number
you get out of the car we smoke the
number we eat some [ __ ] tic tacs we
play some cologne on you so nobody knows
nothing you head for the lincoln tunnel
beautiful and you come back with your
weed and you had a night out already
yeah that's it you're everything i had
the dinner in a movie
yeah
so that was the whole part of it that's
you're not only getting the weed but
you're also bringing it over the state
you're going through a tunnel
there was that suspense you know when i
went on
when i went on 235th to get the coke i
could have bought coke in jersey
let me tell you something when i was 21
i was like people that are 40 now you
know it was illusion like this you know
and that way if you live in l.a
they want you to uh people come to you
and go this paint is phenomenal he
painted
yeah blah blah mitzi shore's house well
he's
uh you know dennis quaid's dentist you
know
so
we used to go into the city and it was
basically 20 cheaper but you still had
to pay for the total and gas
and
yeah there was a little danger maybe
getting shot or robbed or a chase
they were cool colombian dudes and they
took us into that little disc attack and
they had [ __ ] fighting
and then we go on it was a disc attack
but in the daytime they had [ __ ]
fighting then they'd sweep the floors
during the daytime during the daytime so
we go in the afternoon to get caught why
go over there at night and compete with
everybody else you're right now the cops
are looking for you we go in the
afternoon sightseeing
what are you doing on 135th street we
got [ __ ] lost officer
we went we wanted to see harlem we
wanted to see mlk boulevard and we made
a [ __ ] right this guy don't know how
to drive he's puerto rican i'm sorry
and the cop will let you go you know
what i'm saying because the person
they're going to ask you is why are you
over here 1350 absolutely
did you ever have anxiety like i was
talking about never never oh my god
never
never it was my world i love all that
[ __ ] if you got laced i thought that was
like a bonus that's a bonus most people
get laced
isn't it
i i don't know
you can't talk to him he has a better
story if he got late at 12
at 12 i was getting ready for my bar
mitzvah and i was having play dates and
joey was doing acid or whatever he was
doing you gave me anxiety just saying
that 12 you have play dates yeah i don't
know what the [ __ ] it's a play date when
somebody comes over
maybe maybe 12 is too old for a player i
don't know maybe i was having sleepovers
then who know maybe i i upgraded to the
sleepover but still i wasn't [ __ ]
i hadn't even had a sip of alcohol i
don't think i probably at most had some
like mana chef it's jewish wine that's
terrible
that's all i had there's no way there's
nothing wrong with that there's nothing
no that's beautiful it was two different
societies yeah oh my gosh it was two
different uh you know i'm looking at
this trump today and i'm looking at a
caveman
i'm looking at a guy that's 60 but he's
really a hundred yeah he don't look good
yeah he's not no no it's not that he
don't look good it's that
parts of him how to touch
and i understand where he's going with
some of this you know i get it
you know and uh
but it's like he's 60 or whatever i
don't know i think he's
but he's really a hundred i was 50 when
i was 30. like i already had the old man
mentality like i was already a [ __ ]
old man when i was 30. by 30 i had done
it already i got divorced i went to
prison i got married i had a kid you
know i was done
i was done already so i already already
you know i got crabs my heart got broken
you know my heart got broken four times
you know what i'm saying like so by the
time you're 30 already you're like all
right
now i know how to play this
[ __ ] field now you know what
i'm saying i'm gonna go for mine now for
10 years you're nicely nice everybody's
really nice and [ __ ]
but you know sometimes people's thinking
is [ __ ] uh
a little older he's thinking this other
thing i don't [ __ ] know i just think
he looks like he's in over his head i
mean wouldn't we all be it's
you think it's gonna be this cakewalk
it's not i think there was leon vega who
said something today that was pretty
interesting because uh
for the first time
we got a guy that's doing everything he
said maybe it's not because he's a
politician you know
yeah it's a little food for thought you
know he's doing everything he said he
was going to do so
maybe
that's scary
but he's doing everything he
themselves people are panicking right
now everybody's panicking right now you
know they signed that [ __ ] immigrant
fact
i'm not even an immigrant and i think
i'm i'm worried they're gonna send me
back to ireland
so he could build jobs and [ __ ] and
that's his name he's gonna build that
wall and milk it
i'm boiling potato [ __ ] he's gonna be
you need a [ __ ] labor he's gonna milk
how long does that wall gonna [ __ ] be
they said like two thousand miles
like they're like that's how long the
border is but then like i was watching
something there there is a wall in some
parts and then other parts it's like a
river
it looks like a gate because uh freddy
is in el paso it was freddy soto so when
we went there
he showed me there's like holes in the
gate i mean there is a gate but it's
it's not really there should be
something how crazy is that when you
look to help when you go to el paso you
look left
yes [ __ ]
what is this right there and you look
right and it looks like
it's like shanties lee
it's like it's poor right there right
there in front of you right there
right [ __ ] there you sit there you're
like jesus christ that big of a
difference
people are on top of each other i mean i
haven't been to el paso in 10 years i
don't know what yeah mexico looks like
today so from out of touch
but san diego the uh you could see
mexico from san diego what's the uh
border there
what's the famous one everybody went to
tijuana
because me and my little sister we were
driving to la jolla this was years ago
driving to la jolla we went too far and
i was like damn this neighborhood got
bad fast this is san diego there's a bad
neighborhood
i did it one night or one night down
there
and it was one of those shows that's
supposed to start at eight but it
started at 9 30 because of a laker game
yeah
so it was already gonna be a two o'clock
[ __ ] night to me you know what i'm
saying
we didn't finish that show till like one
oh and when i pulled out of there it was
like [ __ ] harlem
in
1968 it was [ __ ] it's weird
though right
i made that left i don't know what the
name of that town is
there's a name it's not san diego it's a
little town where it switches
it's [ __ ] scary it really is scary i
don't the guys
i am petrified in mexico
i went to mexico one time in el paso
and that was enough for me i knew i
didn't belong there i knew that a guy
like me should get into a lot of trouble
there there's no reason for me to be
down there
because what am i gonna do i'm either
gonna it's not like i'm gonna go to
mexico to sightsee the cultural spots
yeah i'm gonna go get some [ __ ] food
yeah yeah you know i'm gonna walk the
street vendors but come on
come on you know i'm gonna think i'm
cute and go get two thousand volumes oh
yeah for three pennies a piece and drink
that's how they used to party but that's
how everybody did it i can't i can't so
many people did that it went down to the
one by el paso
and i got a five second i've been to a
lot of bad places i just knew
it wasn't for me and forget about
nighttime yeah this was daytime nice on
a saturday at 11 in the morning
real easy we ate my friend bought a
leather jacket the comic i was working
with a leather jacket
and
that was enough for me it's so weird
like it's
i didn't grow up
like riding i grew up like upper middle
class probably but the town i grew up in
was very similar to the people that
like are like trump they're like it's
very
rigid yeah
the most white but it's weird like
growing up in that town and then coming
out here and dating someone from
englewood
i knew in my head that places like that
existed
but until you go there you really don't
even though you know it so like i
with this stuff it's like
like you were saying with trump he's a
100 year old and a seven-year-old body
he knows that there's poor people sure
but he he
i don't even it's ignoring but it's i
don't even know if he can really wrap
his head around
what that means to to be that poor yeah
like a lot of people where i grew up
voted for him which is fine i don't care
who you vote for but they were like he's
one of us and i'm like he wouldn't even
drive through our neighborhood to get to
the airport what are you talking about
he's not one of us he's never been to
where we're from he's never been down in
south philly just hanging out in the
streets
you know the closest he got was the the
the debates well they didn't do that
though that was hillary clinton
that went and did the dnc he didn't do
philly
i really don't know much about the guy
and like except
it's just he's different from my contact
as a kid and i watched that thing and he
had
he was the owner of the uh
usfl oh yeah yeah like you know
like i told somebody one time you know
he's always doing something
if you do 30 things you're going to fail
at 10 of them yeah you can't hold that
against somebody when people would say
well your hotel went bankrupt your
college went bankrupt
but look at all the things that did stay
open you know there's got to be some
value in that i don't know if it
qualifies to be an american [ __ ]
president right right but i think that
people just got so sick of
you know before whoever voted for him
is sick of what's going on yeah he
really got to that agreement
yes he got to them with keywords
something very interesting
you know
i know there's a lot of middle eastern
people that listen to this and muslims
and you know i love you i [ __ ] around i
crack stupid jokes but
let me tell you something man you know
what was one of the destructions of
miami in a smaller
scale
marielle boatlift i'm cuban i'm very
proud to be cuban
but as a cuban american if you ask the
people in miami who lived there at that
time period
to be honest with you
the mario boatlift was one of the worst
things that happened to that state and
even my hometown west new york there was
a battle
for two or three years these animals
were battling and what people don't
understand is
they
were animals yeah
i hate to
mental health places but he emptied the
prisons where
they put you in there and they there's
no feeding schedule they feed you
there's no showers there's no tv
you know sometimes he'll come in with a
loaf of bread at four [ __ ] guys you
know it's a loaf of bread between four
years figure it out [ __ ]
you know and he he brought him into
miami you know so today i heard some
guys saying that on the news that a
jewish guy was saying that
they're syrians
there's no
proof
that they're involved in any terrorism
whatsoever
you know but
i think even like the cute mario boat
harbor
situation should have been but they
didn't know so now they should know
well but i thought the the boat harbor
they did that intentionally they they
emptied the prisons they were like okay
you want to go goodbye here take these
and they sent the prisoners it was
[ __ ] you know and it's amazing
because there was no internet then
so nobody who knew what was really going
on about six years ago i got invited to
do a
what's [ __ ] your boy's spanish friend
dominic has a cuban friend that he's
been tight with for 50 years there he's
an actor he did all the miami vices and
all the bad boys good guy
he turned me on to a guy can't think of
his name guy called me and he goes i
cannot send you the script
it's this but he goes i'll meet you at
this coffee shop
where do you live i met him at the
hunger
aroma where the [ __ ] the lion is out
the door
and he goes i'll leave it with you there
and i'll sit at the other table and
write and read it and let me know what
you think
this script like usually i read four
pages dog and i'm like i'll read this
later
this [ __ ] script i didn't put
it down to like page 68 and by that time
i had white tears from my eyes and it
was about
what really happened during the mario
harbor that we didn't know about like
there was international pirates not i'm
not international pirates there was like
you would come to like any other [ __ ]
thing like what the chinese people do
you would come to me and say i go up
eleanor i don't know do me a favor
i don't know how to ask you this you're
my only friend and you have a boat
can we get on your boat right now and go
to cuba and pick up my grandmother like
[ __ ] like that yeah on the way back
people would stop us
pull the grandmother off shoot you
and say give us 50 000 for your grandma
i mean that's it was [ __ ] hard
like this was i go how did you get it i
go listen first of all i cannot give you
uh
a whatever on this because i don't know
any about this he goes neither do you
nor three quarter of a million people
knew that this even existed because
there was no internet right right there
was no internet these stories
only p you know they were like in the
eight in the 80s there was a time leave
you lived in coral gables
you could wake up go outside
just to thank god and look over by the
ocean and there'd be a kilo a bag of
cocaine in the ocean
that's ready for you to steal
like that was just part of it or
you could just [ __ ] see 20 bags of
weed in your little [ __ ] canal there
this was this is just occupational
hazard it was happening in aspen
colorado where they were finding bears
dead
and a bag a duffel bag eaten they would
eat the coke they would drop the [ __ ]
duffel bag from a plane and three puerto
ricans and they're supposed to pick it
up they didn't read the compass right
but [ __ ] smoking the bears walking
around minding his own business
he gets hit in the head with a duffel
bag he goes what's in the duffel bag he
takes a big chunk out of that
[ __ ] to rip it open and what do
you think is in there 98 cocaine i think
i saw that scene in narcos dies of a
heart attack yeah and nelson they find
the bed next to the blood three days
later they had those all the [ __ ]
time
that is crazy
so i i don't i don't
like i said you know i just
when i read that script it [ __ ] with
me for a couple days oh i bet i was like
this is
this was [ __ ] up nobody and then
scarface they show you when they're
interviewing him
and they already hadn't tell on what was
going on who was coming in the cubans
weren't saying nothing they were telling
remember when he beats up manolo because
why are they taking you would you tell
them because i told them that you i
wasn't a psychiatrist what's that line
jesus christ enzo you should have told
them you were a horse yeah right right
oh [ __ ] i can't remember how it goes lee
put on scarface stephen bauer stephen
he's a good friend of mine he's like
sweetie
oh you're kidding me
i'll text him i know he's around here
somewhere i don't know exactly
my really good friend used to be his
assistant and so he's she would bring
him to my shows a couple years ago
he's [ __ ] great though
he's [ __ ] funny man
i i ran into sebastian maniscalco and i
was with him and he goes is that
manolo you know
and i go yeah and i go you know me and
the 80 stars listen to me i had him and
angel salazar oh no in studio and
they're fun
and lisa was purple when angel would
just get up are you dying
he would just get up and go do a blast
anger and come back and he was a
different person here you go right here
right here
oh let's see
yeah sanitarium that's what he says to
him
that's what he says yeah
but it's so accurate how they depicted
this
well except that they put some
non-cubans on the bus well none of these
people
exactly only one cuban there's 80 people
right
steven's not even cuban yeah
doug this movie when you put squadrons
great it becomes a comedy now this is a
[ __ ] absolutely right here hit this
one this is another one that he [ __ ]
kills you with this
he kills you
antonio montana
and you what you call yourself
jesus christ
so good that's cool
hey my father he was uh from the united
states
y'all like you you know
he was a yankee
i used to take me a lot to the movies
you know i learned i watched the guys
like
huffy bogart they skagged me
they teach me to talk
i always know one day i'm coming here
united states listen
i saw this february 1st 1984. oh wow at
the sequakis harmon cove at the matinee
and it was sold the [ __ ] out we had to
sit that's in
see caucus
right off the plane i'm in the middle of
the weeds listen to me my friends took
me right off the newark [ __ ] place
you see that old guy right there that's
sitting over there
i did a movie with him
in 19 no in 2007 when i got off the
cocaine and we became friends he's an
old irish guy he was in dog day
afternoon oh yeah he was john something
i think he's dead now because they put
him in that sag home up there
but me and john ran for like six or
seven months maybe a year after that i'd
pick him up on wednesdays and take him
to church he refused to go down the
santa monica church because i don't want
to [ __ ] be sitting there with gay
people oh that was my favorite church
yeah and he would he would go to the one
on sunset sacred heart sacred sacrament
but every time i'd take him down on
wednesdays there was a lot of chinese
people we couldn't figure it out we'd go
every wednesday and we finally figured
out pacquiao went there for lunch oh wow
for the lunch time that's the master
there's no priest they just put an album
on
on a wednesday because they used to do
latin i've been to the latin
massachusetts i've never been to a latin
mass there yeah they have i think
they're 10 o'clock on sundays is latin
did that by accident once it's so funny
how you know
you watch all this [ __ ] like this isn't
a [ __ ] joke but i meant that you were
right they they didn't cast any cubans
but i meant the actual situation
how it happened you know them coming in
how they got in the country and stuff
like that that was pretty accurate yeah
correct yeah yeah
i mean it was uh
they interrogated you and they some
people got like angel salazar and
stephen bauer ah
the bass player from ozzy
well um they came over with the take one
twitch
so they just move you around so rudy
grew up in north bergen rudy grew up in
west new york by me and he graduated
high school memorial but then they would
move you again to wherever they needed
cubans oh you know what i'm saying like
i don't know and angel salazar too he
came over on like a bus plan or
something where you go to new york and
they take you to mia angel went
somewhere before new york
yeah they took them somewhere before new
york you know
yeah he uh was in atlantic city and
somehow met my brother billy who you met
the kid is what they call him
and then i saw angel years later he goes
your brother's billy the kid oh [ __ ]
you know what the sad thing made me so
nervous i have no idea about my history
your history yeah like
cuban i'm coming no no no i'm completely
inaccurate with my [ __ ] in your family
it was my uncle who told me that i was
born in cuba got it okay i just found
this out that you weren't 20 years ago
no well that you were no i thought i was
born in new york city for twenty [ __ ]
didn't
yes i did i thought you always said you
were born in cuba and then my uncle was
like what are you talking about you were
born in cuba he goes i was there when
you came over
your mom had to pay some people on a
plane and him you and your dad came over
and they got a new york city birth
certificate
from the jewish because my dad knew some
jews in the lower east side when he came
from cuba he was young
my uncle [ __ ] spilt the beans in 84
and told me some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
it was like a week from hell it was like
somebody
telling you everything that you thought
he's the one that told me he goes
did you even know why your mom had an
alias
and i go no i didn't [ __ ] know i
never even thought to ask you she
murdered a guy that was raping her
sister
had a dance
okay so she was 16. he got a white she
goes he goes i still remember being at
home and her and i said my other sister
leaving and i always noticed while i was
growing up that those those two sisters
were always tight they even look like
each other that's not murder by the way
that's justice but they still looked on
my mom so my mom had to leave overnight
in like a raft no and they took her to
chicago and then she went to new york
and then she met a puerto rican family
so when she went back to cuba
she took the name of the puerto rican
chick's mom
sophia cecilia okay
so my mother's bar was under the name of
sofia cecilia
but there was a problem she paid social
security to sophia cecilia
so when i died when my mother died i got
no social security oh because my mom was
the norah valdez
do you understand me so
i didn't know all this [ __ ] until
[ __ ] 1984 it was a week of me serious
yeah
that's awful right after you graduated
high school right two years afterward
night and i just came out here i needed
to see family i go let me go out there
and see my uncle and hang out with him
it was a week of torture the week ended
with us pulling pieces on each other
on [ __ ] vermont boulevard for is it
vermont
it's the last street all the way down
there not vermont yeah i think it is
vermont whatever the [ __ ] yeah close
that take a cab
virgil vermont all that yeah
he has a mexican bar down the wall the
way down there what the western west
western well it's the last street before
and i didn't i
i came out there that's where we had the
shootout
and when i got i got a ticket for having
a phone app
in hollywood and my wife goes don't go
on the 110
go on uh that street i don't know what
it was uh yeah it was [ __ ] vermont
but take it all the way to western and
hook a left down there and there's a
left that takes you right into city hall
right into where you go for your tickets
and [ __ ] and when i was at the left i
looked up and the bar was still there
and i go this motherfucker's still alive
even though i lived here and i wanted to
kill him
i never went over there all those years
i had an hour i said if i ever fail here
on the way out i'll go shoot him then
take the plane to colorado go chop up my
wife and then take another play in the
jersey and [ __ ] slaughter the cops
come get me you know i was just gonna go
i'm a little boy oh [ __ ] yeah
so i thought about it i had at that
point
i didn't talk to him for like 25 [ __ ]
years
wow and i that's the first time i didn't
say no then i got an audition for a
movie
and i had to go up to the pacific coast
highway
and i was driving the long way
and i stopped and i go
i've been here before
and i go what the [ __ ] and i walked out
there and i stopped the car i go when
the [ __ ] was i here is this joey is this
a dream
and i [ __ ] it was 2009. and i picked
up the phone i called my uncle i
apologize
and he [ __ ] was excited and we hooked
up for years now we haven't talked for
three years ago now we're mad at each
other
my cousin [ __ ] it all up but nobody's
gonna call nobody to apologize so
[ __ ] so
my wife is the one that told them all to
go [ __ ] themselves
my wife finally said let me ask you guys
a question so you're mad at me or coco
that's fine but this little girl loves
you [ __ ] this is the game
you're gonna play now you cut off i
don't like when they yeah they just
played shitty [ __ ] whatever so my
wife was the one i said you know what
you're absolutely right [ __ ] the
[ __ ] and [ __ ] yeah i got a
sister-in-law she she had a problem like
argues with her parents whatever but
they never stop putting the kids never
stop seeing the kids does that make
sense like she's like oh i [ __ ] i
want to flip out on my mom but she lets
the kids go there see them she drops
them off go hang out never take it out
on the kids it's not fair if the adults
fight the adults fight [ __ ] happens
but never the kids that's [ __ ] up
what's up lisa i was so i was
i was thinking about this today it was
uh
were you guys excited to leave home when
you left home i know like was it to move
out yeah i couldn't i couldn't wait to
move out and i was it's not i had a i
have a great family but even my extended
family but there was a there was a lot
of fighting and we never really super
got along like with some parts of it
and i was always
i was happy to not have to go to that
anymore but now that it's been like six
years i kind of miss it a little bit
even even with the fighting even even
with all that
because it's what you knew you grew up
in yeah i wasn't i wouldn't say excited
i guess i was excited to try something
different but i moved out of my mom's
right to la
so i didn't leave
and stay in philly you know if i would
have moved out
and only moved to like a nicer place in
philly
i don't know maybe things would have
went different
i was a kid i traveled i never did i
traveled my mom
how did you get to do that
my mom my mom liked traveling so every
summer for sure we went to miami and
every christmas to puerto rico
that was always a given sometimes i go
to miami
and then once my uncle came to visit me
then my uncle said you're more than
welcome to come out my mom's like i'm
not getting on that plane
so i would fly by myself to l.a
he'd pick me up i'd stay out here for a
week in those days they treated you like
a soldier
it was a regular flight but they put you
in first class close to the stewardess
they give you wings
a coloring book a hat
a [ __ ] pair of drums wings they gave
you everything
and then you got off the plane first now
you get off the plane last and they give
you a bunch of paperwork like you're a
[ __ ] farm prison oh yeah because
everything's on high alert everything
has to be in first class like this
little girl i flew away no no they're
selling them
eminem's manager's daughter flew with me
okay and i was talking down the plane
and she was telling me how hard it was
for her to fly like
jesus parents have to be at the terminal
before the plane takes off and check in
something just [ __ ] ridiculous like
it was just crazy but i would fly out
here
every summer and then miami for two
three weeks and my mother would come
down and get me and we'd all fly back
together i'm so jealous of you no man my
mom dug it i drove to michigan when i
was a kid shut up i used to go take a
bus to the jersey shore about myself
when i was in the jersey shore we did
that i used to take a bus to the city
like nothing in those days you know
take a bus i went to florida my first
trip i was 18 on a plane we went for
senior week and it was just me and a
bunch of girls that got kicked out of
school not the ones that graduated with
me that i was supposed to be hanging
with
but so we all went to fort lauderdale oh
that was killer and then my my friend my
best friend melissa she got a little
attached to this little cuban kid she
wanted to bring him home
he was 12. i'm like where are we going
with this kid she was feeding them
lobster i'm like
this is getting uncomfortable
and then i used to go to virginia beach
when i was in high school there was a
plane to virginia beach for 22 dollars
what
and you flew from newark to virginia
beach the whole town was 18. i'm telling
you
i did that twice
i like traveling and then
once i got into high school and became a
criminal i was taking planes i was
leaving town every four weeks you know
what i'm saying i was always leaving
town but as a criminal how can you leave
i mean what do you mean i would i would
front the kilo i would rob somebody's
house they'd be like defending the
contractor that was already in the that
was already included in the price of my
thought of the robbery
that better be 200 100 in there for a
plane ticket
where i don't know i decide when i get
to the airport because in those days you
could pay cash at the airport with no
[ __ ] problem
so i could go to the airport look where
the flight's going excuse me i like the
10 40 flight to los angeles yeah can i
see identification are you gonna pay for
this diners club [ __ ] no diners
cash that's a real card yeah yeah but it
used to be more popular back then dining
club american express
uh visa maybe not then discover came
they were like johnny come lately i
don't like discovering we need another
show no one ever takes discover that's
what my mom says oh i took them i took
them to the corners those [ __ ]
i'm on the [ __ ] discovers top 10 list
they'll never fall i [ __ ] discover
over they made a mistake and sent me
checks before the credit card shut those
blank checks really
they would send you like three blank
checks to really torment you
that's the last thing you send the coke
fiend is three checks from one of those
visa companies because the bank don't
give a [ __ ]
and now you can't
of course now now he can't wait years
ago the check cash in place would cash
it
we got identification
and they call the bank and saturday
who's close you know i can't call this
governor okay we'll give you this this
guy will have to come now they got
24-hour goddamn people
[ __ ] when i'm sitting there broke
my little girlfriend with that hot
little monkey sitting at the boss
surrounded by dudes and [ __ ] she's
sitting next to a little korean chick i
am flat broke there's nobody to rob i'm
out of jewelry
i got nothing dog i got [ __ ] nothing
i'm sitting there and i said man in that
move i took a box of those discover
checks let me see if i still got them oh
i went over there they were there i
ripped it lesson
i took one for 200 like a weather center
200.
if you're going to walk out nice you
might as well dance jesus christ i took
and filled that
took it to my local bank
i [ __ ] went in there when i when she
stopped when she asked me how do i want
it
and i told her once nothing but benny's
nothing but benjamin franklin's
i couldn't believe i drove out of there
leaf for 20 minutes i kept looking
behind me i thought the cops are
somewhere
it was unfucking believable and i showed
up at the bar like johnny gumba buying
everybody did give him a martini give
her a martini give him a drink give him
a drink i'm all a drink throwing
hundreds down the little chicks like oh
look who it is
forget about it you know what and then
monday morning 901
this is bank of [ __ ] boulder can we
speak to jose i'm right here listen
you got about 15 minutes to show with
that g beau larue you're over [ __ ]
your account you couldn't even
she goes we don't even know how they
cast that
well that's your problem goodbye click
what i hung up the [ __ ] phone he's
right though but i already had my car
payment i was three down i had a [ __ ]
every night i had to come home and hide
my car in the trees and weeds and put
explosives around the car and [ __ ]
glass i heard a repo man you have no
idea
you have no [ __ ] idea and i was going
to a nugget game and i got hit on black
ice
and i twisted the rim i go down there
the rim is [ __ ]
uh
2 000 per rim this dummy that was on the
show last week mike kessler works on an
accurate place and i'm like leave the
keys in the car i'm gonna go how many
times i robbed that accurate [ __ ]
place
that super place and they would blame
another employee
one day i went and picked the whole
glass off
walked in there and took the cash box
and went home mike was like it was only
300 hours i go in those days for me
the rent was four
so i showed up with two i took 100
bought a half gram some adam cheese and
some freshly squeezed orange juice for
money you know
you know how we do it you gotta cover
the spread constantly in my world they
might have invented security cameras for
joey d yeah i i definitely believe i
didn't [ __ ] believe one night
at night after comedy in those days i
would go to uh the supermarket which was
uh
king supers
then i would buy a piece of adam cheese
i would buy those nice crackers
the cheese with the red package around
it and you can you get your knife and
you cut that [ __ ] thing off i didn't
even have a knife i would just stick my
[ __ ] eleanor with people
big eleanor team and buy the car segonia
weaver
right i would [ __ ] eat those
that [ __ ] [ __ ] i would get a piece of
cheese and a container freshly squeezed
orange juice
and i go to the acura dealership and sit
there and just watch the cars go by and
look at the new accuracy in fact one
night i caught a cop pulled it
and said what are you doing here i'm
sitting here [ __ ] eating a piece of
cheese
looking at the cars he goes you know
what do you think of that car me and the
cops started talking we became friends
20 20 20 30 minutes with chit chat
he didn't know i was casing the joint
he had no idea
and that's not a weird response what are
you doing here i'm eating cheese and
looking at cars
that seems like the cop was cool he just
sat and talked yeah it's one in the
morning they sit there they call for
backup just in case i was a lookout i
know look i look like i look up to you
i'm just sitting in a piece of cheese
looking at the [ __ ] labels do you
think it's harder to be a criminal now
than it was back then yeah i wouldn't
even try there's nothing you could do i
mean you got to be so tech savvy to be a
goddamn criminal today
it's not the tech savvy i'm worried
about
what's the cameras everywhere
yeah but there's a camera everywhere
there's a camera everywhere if i tell
you we're going to get to a point where
that they know already right now they
already know if you ever said they're
telling them they know they don't
they're not even telling you forget the
smartphone oh no but if i'm a [ __ ]
going to do something bad there ain't no
phone i already know that good this is a
traffic device so right now if i smack
you in the [ __ ] mouth over by
lancashire and 54th street here
it'll show up okay
try to grab your ted i throw you on the
floor
right
they can't find me they're going to find
me within 20 minutes because they're
going to press a button and there's a
satellite that's been watching that
particular location they're going to get
a picture of me
they're going to show the general public
a different picture from a bodega but
they're going to cover their asses but
they're going to have the i know they
they have the technology already i agree
hate that's how they did in new york new
york you go to times square within two
minutes you they know you're there they
know name date of birth what you did
what do you owe what cards you didn't
[ __ ] use last year everything i heard
the airlines too
as soon as you call the [ __ ] airlines
your [ __ ] everything comes up do you
use waze the app
thing no
okay so this it's just like a quicker
ways they'll give you to get around
driving here they were like there's an
accident 2.2 miles ahead there's
somebody pulled over to the side that
somebody ran out of gas there's a
traffic light with a camera they [ __ ]
tell you everything
the whole time i'm like holy [ __ ] this
is a
complete tracking device because it's
hooked up to whatever you're saying
that's watching
all of us every second it's impossible
to be a criminal
what i don't have to be invisible the
difference between a criminal
the stupid criminal things i did
would all be on camera
yeah i wouldn't even know what to do i
couldn't go in an office
you can't rob
a business because every business has
visible cameras
it's like those cops getting caught at
that weed store these dummies went in
there and tried to rob didn't know that
they got they got invisible cameras
everywhere
everywhere the cameras you see they're
working
but they're decoys they're working
you're gonna go up something spray paint
them you can spray paint those
[ __ ] all you want because
there's 50 more of those [ __ ] things
and they got you from every [ __ ]
angle and if not you have to assume yeah
if you're not assuming so you have to go
into those places with a [ __ ] mask so
wait a second i gotta do all this work
they could do what rob is 7-eleven
a bank there's no way now they can they
could follow you with the traffic
cameras from 7-eleven to your house like
they could it's like the night of did
you watch that show oh man that was
great so nothing more they followed that
you believe that nothing won which is a
real [ __ ] tutorial that's my heart
you know oh man he's great
let's say you tried to rob big time drug
dealers
that's the only occupation i could do is
set up drug dealing or just con people
out of money because that's
that's the second thing there's always a
sucker yeah there's always that's
scary my mom was sending money to uh she
read this thing about this indian
reservation and she felt bad her white
guilt kicked in and they still she sent
like ten dollars you know and they send
her every month
new ones we have oh this happened on the
reservation today can you send i'm like
are you really serious praying on these
old women
i mean i'm sure they do it to all
people old people oh they go after them
quick
sick
yeah i gotta come up with a good scam
because i need money you know um
got any ideas lee
i have tons of ideas
i mean selling coke is obsolete
oh he has money in it but you got to be
on your belly to sell it so
you got to be underground yeah
no but you still got to be out you got
to be out on your belly because you got
to be out there [ __ ] no i hear what
you're saying but you got it you can't
you know yeah i could send lee you know
but i just made leah partner when i
lived in an aspen i had a dude named
carl hall
my brother until this day even though
his little bots he's my brother i miss
him i still laugh at his [ __ ] jokes
listen man that kid would come to me and
say give me
a half hours and fifties
i don't know what i charge him
and we did this
from july to november
i could give him
10 grams of coke
and packages bundled up and he cut a
deal with me right off the bat i'm
taking a grandma off the top and 50
bucks take it
because i'm still going to make this
amount and this is going to go
he would come back three times in one
night
nobody's so cooked like this kid that's
something he was from the south
and you know how to party man come on
let's do a [ __ ] blast yeah i got more
of this i know the [ __ ] who
processed this [ __ ] yeah yeah and he did
give me 50 bucks he just [ __ ] banged
people out he was the best salesman i
ever saw
reading that kid it's amazing oh he was
possible he was hilarious
he'd pick up chicks every night
every night he had a different woman he
lived in employee housing
what kind of housing employee housing
that's where you work at a hotel
let's say you move from here to snowmass
village what do you mean and you get a
job as security hotel they're all for
you you want to employ yeah you live in
a a four bedroom apartment you know you
have to share it with others you share
the kitchen the bathroom and the living
space with other people yeah i've heard
it but it's just you know 75 a week
compared to paying 1200
and it's a pretty good start you take it
right out of your check you don't even
know what's going on i live in the
[ __ ] employer housing when i was
security at the crestwood like a
[ __ ] where is that they crest
with this snowmass village that's how i
know about it
i can't believe you work security yeah
right
night security from five to one
i'm the guy i'm the midnight
i was yeah that was me i'm the guy i'm
the midnight commandant
i would work
i would work five to
one
okay
five nights a week i had to wear a green
shirt with beige pants
they gave me the jacket do you have like
a stick no sticks flashlights
walkie-talkie
security was basically how to check the
jacuzzis turn them all off
make sure the gym was closed made sure
the laundry room was open
made sure there was wood out for people
to light their fires
i had to walk around the buildings twice
but the primary job was picking people
up at the airport ah i'd have three or
four runs and it's supposed to take you
10 minutes it took me two hours that's
how i did i did 10 miles an hour like i
[ __ ]
did a couple stops yeah i would stop at
the holiday inn
and get a [ __ ] cocktail i knew where
to buy a great i knew when i first got
that security job i still knew where to
get quaaludes wait
so i would take the van up to aspen but
people be calling where are you i'm
making a loop right now and i'd still be
an asthma come on bro i'd be up with
those [ __ ] quails that's what i was
gonna say like what about the people you
were picking up they'd have to wait it's
snowing they were there
in the world and i could tell them a
story i could tell in the car spun out i
used to tell them but i had a walking
talk
i remember there was no gps lee
okay completely different worldly so
let's say they would say to me a guy is
landing at 7.50
okay okay that means he's landing at 750
and he's got to get his luggage and walk
down and his skis that's a 35 [ __ ]
minute
40 minute hike because you got to wait
for luggage and then you got to wait for
the big things and everybody bring skis
yeah okay so
i knew that i was good till 8 30 8 40.
so i would leave there at seven and i
would do 10 150 miles an hour to aspen
i'm sorry about the water bottles i
would go to the internet restaurant
way before that burger and all this
other punk [ __ ] yeah
and then that was a sandwich shop owned
by uh oh wow really that was the name it
was the originals it was owned by a dude
that's now still a restaurant tour up
there and a friend of mine from buffalo
who still comes to my shows today this
is 1985
and this kid still comes to my shows
that's amazing my dog
oh what the [ __ ] hercules right and his
dog kali who were goombas she was a
female she was a wolf and he would come
to the house and the two dogs would
[ __ ] play
but i [ __ ] bumped into steve chavo
you know how many years i thought about
that kid steve chavonni
he was one of the best kids i haven't
met my i mean i've just been fresh out
of new york city i'm in this new city
with my buddy jimmy berkel who's god
rest his soul he was my goomba my
guardian angel
and uh he had a girlfriend so on the
weekends i'd be lonely and i'd go to the
in-n-out place it was open until like
[ __ ] nine
and that's the first place i ever tasted
a sandwich with sprouts i almost vomited
right there and they're both laughing
because they're both from buffalo i
would have thrown up oh my god the first
time a dog they had some
they had some [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] was that was the first
time i ready to say i grew up in new
york and that was the first time i ever
had a sandwich or russian dressing on it
they changed my worldly they i don't
even know what they're right they had
like turkey
and they even put bacon and avocado in
those days and russian dressing it was
off the [ __ ] chain
it was a small plate smaller than this
you had a stick on the stairs there'd be
a line around the corner because if you
go in buy a sandwich only you could fit
three people in there wow so i became
friends with steve chavoni around that
place was captain video i took him for
like 10 g's i had a [ __ ] pyramid
cocaine scam right one of those cocaine
yeah a pyramid
give me 10 000 at five o'clock sure yeah
tomorrow night at six i bring back
[ __ ] fifteenth that's all right that
is and you just didn't bring back your
friends the last time i've been for a
year and a half with him but the last
time i skipped
i got a letter from his wife what
happened i was counting
waiting we're still waiting the chrysler
stock is down
wait he told his wife he got involved in
the
oh my god bro i had about 90 different
people involved in that cocaine scheme
come on
that's how it works you got it that's
how it works listen everybody wants to
make money i'm going to make you
scarface
without selling coke how are you going
to do that how much you got under the
bed eight thousand what's it doing for
you nothing i'm gonna put your money to
[ __ ] work okay
you're putting your money to sleep i'm
gonna put your money to work here
i don't want the eight give me five to
start off what do i get 6 500 back when
the next day so let me get this straight
at six o'clock i'm going to give you 5
000 and the next night you're going to
give me 6 500 how does this work
don't worry how it works you're going to
give it to me you know
and after that the first man who talks
loses
either gonna give it to me or not don't
say a [ __ ] word
you should do it ted talks right there
you just lost i'm sorry well when do i
have to give you the money uh hello
tick-tock
you know what i'm saying you want to
make venus we gotta [ __ ] come up with
the guinness let's go with a bunch of
popular and get this party started
you should you should do a ted talks on
how to make a carrot a pyramid but i
would give it i would go up there
i would go to the internet house i would
park i would eat a sandwich hug those
guys talk to them they would give me a
butter weed and then i would [ __ ] run
across the street in the snow it was a
little chateau hotel
the hotels were the cutest thing you
ever saw in your life
how do i know because i lived with my
ex-wife in there for about a month and a
half before we got in the boat before we
got into employee housing
and that's where i got the album done
with mirrors by aerosmith i almost threw
it out the window i was waiting for
[ __ ] the biggest album ever
and nothing that's where i listen to
that cassette
it's right close to the jail with ted
bundy
jumped out of the window i mean right
across 30 yards it's probably not there
now
and right across from this uh big uh
lumber type deal and
i lived in that chateau for probably six
weeks man wow
but in there the the chateau keeper
not the owner he sold quaaludes
that were made in like woody creek by
[ __ ] young cocaine chemists they were
giving them to don johnson and who's the
writer with the cigarette
with the buffalo fear and loathing in
las vegas
that's what he was selling down in woody
creek and that was he would give me four
for 20 bucks they were 10 bucks a piece
in those days thompson hunter s times
they were 10 bucks a piece but i told
him once i got how can i give you ten i
was just paying for in new york and
that's new york yeah he goes out right i
give him three for four
that's how much money that slick
[ __ ] was making
christ wow
i've only been there it's been once the
comedy festival
95 i think i did
i wasn't in it i was just there with my
first ex-fiance jesus christ how are the
quaaludes he was doing coke but i no i'm
kidding uh i didn't get any quails they
wouldn't give me any it was fun though
it's [ __ ] crazy that place beautiful
too nervous for me i don't ski
is that the same thing like the
snowmobile the adrenaline like how do
you pitch someone
alone they're loan sharking you money
for cocaine
kinda i don't know i would go to guys
like you though
you're my brother you're my brother i
know you for 10 years you know i've
always been kind of kinky but he's
always been cool with me man i would go
to guys the guy's kid plays with his kid
yeah these are the guys i want to make a
quick 1500 so i can get a girlfriend on
this side and get that dick sucked
without mama going
you always got to remember you got to
look for the same you got to [ __ ]
racially profile
always
always looking 1500 wait a second
1500
yeah okay and then they'll come to me
and go i want to do it every week
because that's six thousand a week
that's six thousand a month
how would you not want to do that yeah
but then you leave at the last one
after you made [ __ ] 70 grand will you
give a [ __ ] yeah so he took me for 65
who gives a [ __ ] what do you give a [ __ ]
are you crazy
i guess i don't know i've never been
involved in a pyramid scheme before so
get the quaalude either half of it
and zoop to the airport
and pick the [ __ ] up and take
care of the kite half a high as a kite
that time i built a tolerance for
guerrilla biscuits by that time and
you're always 85. you're being paid
right now this is you're on duty yeah 12
15 13 an hour plus tips
all right
i love that you're two hours late and
you're gonna get a tip no oh yeah oh
yeah
oh yeah i get you in every angle i was
getting ski boots but he had a story he
had a story no no no people from texas
they didn't [ __ ] around in those days
those were my main customers when i knew
i had texans coming in that's when i
showed up tip top my goons
with sodas in the car and donuts and
welcome to aspen how are you how was
your trip
where are you from you're a yankee yeah
i'm a yankee what's going on none you're
a dallas cowboys yeah
next thing you know you're talking
you're driving you ski you want to come
ski with me and my family tomorrow let's
do it i got family passes and these guys
are just spitting [ __ ] out of you
because they're on vacation they just
made 200 million dollars last year right
that's what it cost to go up there you
know easily the house the house delights
house at 1985.
okay the guy was uh
on the board of fri of tgi fridays when
his daughters came i got to talk to him
and his daughter's like
i don't know if you know this he's got
20 of these
like i said to me when i signed on here
you guys are supposed to come here all
summer
i've never met you guys for a year and a
half and they're like listen
we got one of these
all over the world
it was a three million dollar house in
1987. we got one of these all over the
world
in every city name a city go ahead
bangkok tel aviv we got a building
this that's how much money they had the
girls were like in college mm-hmm to my
mother's grave i was a co-fan i never
talked to them i never was not anything
perverted that was my job i had a
girlfriend but here's the beauty of it
that my mother's [ __ ] grape
they would drop in those days at the
liquor store
like six girls would come from
california okay
and would drop in those days maybe a
thousand booze the liquor service would
come
the delivery store would come and just
bring them
five cases of hard booze beer
and i would see it and then a week later
i would go well how much was that 1200
that's what they always spend every year
they would drink three beers
and they would leave the rest and i
would drink the [ __ ] right yeah they
would leave all of that and they put it
in cabinets and lock it but i had the
key to the cabinets
oh yeah we would have been selling it we
weren't coming back for a year and a
half i just my buddy had the job before
me and he had it for two or three years
and i said to him one day you don't live
in the house
and he goes no and like a wine i go well
i live in the quarters that's what it
says on my contract as soon as he left i
was in that garage for maybe a month
before i was like you know what i'm
moving on up
i went upstairs to the master bedroom
you should have seen this balcony
[ __ ] hawks what are you gonna do when
they come back they would they would
come back once a year you vacuum you
wash the sheets
you don't want to make a bad deal
you hire [ __ ] somebody that's what i
did yeah i hired [ __ ] three chicks i
gave my grandma blow start cleaning no
stop to this house is [ __ ] bagging
i was one of those chicks lee come
lovely
oh my god i make a kitchen
that's what people do up there they have
cleaning services of course that's it
people come in leave somebody comes in
cleans the house picks back magoo super
wealthy oh my god these people were
[ __ ]
435 far away road
that was the name of it okay and this is
in aspen this isn't snowmass village i
can see how much the house is worth now
uh-oh
see how much it's worth see if it's even
still [ __ ] there village i don't even
know where that is far away road it's
yeah it's aspen colorado down the hill
okay at the basement is the top and then
you have that [ __ ] uh independence
pass yeah where it's it saves you an
hour if you're going to denver but it's
only open
from [ __ ]
july to september okay because it's a
row it's a lane and a half a lot of
people don't like that ride like i had
two tough friends that sat under the
[ __ ] like they were petrified yelling
screaming i'm driving how much it's for
sale right now how much
4.995
wow
and it's for it is for sale
the estimated mortgage is 20 grand a
month is it beat up look at the pace no
it's beautiful seven beds seven bags
hold on there let's see whoa oh yeah no
this place is rocking dog jesus oh my
god you're gonna bring back memories i'm
like there was 12 of us in a three
bedroom roll home with one bag you
should have seen this
oh no they redid that oh my god
yeah they redid that that's beautiful
oh wait a second well oh let me
let's see let's see
they left the windows all the windows
were like that the fireplace let's see
the rest of the pictures lee
quick that around yeah look at that
[ __ ] place
yeah that was the back there that was a
ski and ski out
you could ski and ski out of it yeah all
you had to do was walk over that
mountain right there boom and you when
you put your skin it went downhill it
was like stealing all you had to do was
walk 10 yards
wait till they show you the bedrooms oh
my god but yeah
yeah they really did this i like that
furniture too it's like rough
i wish i was a real girl i knew the
decor
oh my [ __ ] god
look at that sled i would play on that
oh my god joey
i don't think i don't think those people
still own it that obviously i mean
they're selling it what do you mean it's
a different
oh my listen i've been in there
in 30 [ __ ] years i haven't been in
there yeah that house got redone
i have not been in there in 30 [ __ ]
years officially
this last november 86
206.
no no no no no no
wow
that is [ __ ] beautiful
you have a fireplace in your bedroom
i i would be scared to live there but i
would visit
i don't i don't like that you could take
it down no that was never there
that was never that they redid this like
a [ __ ]
are you into that do you ski or you at
that time i did at that time i've never
seen when you move up there you're like
i'm never [ __ ] gonna ski it's too
cold and [ __ ]
and you sit there for two months
and this is all people talk about i
guess if i was around from november 25th
from november 15th the season starts at
the uh thanksgiving day but a week
before that
to [ __ ] april 15th
that's what makes the town tick
yeah gomez village gotta got in the
summer people come and they come for the
balloon festival
and they do the tour de france where
people ride their bicycles around a
[ __ ] hill tiddly doo
and they you know they have that type of
[ __ ] and that's back in the day i don't
know what they have now yeah party spot
you want to get your dick sucked in that
day you went to aspen
and noticed that like now i can't now
it's like everywhere else i've sucked a
dick and asked but did you really but in
those days
but in those days i love you eleanor
aspen was like
like
i don't know like i remember being in a
restaurant like the first week i was
there and there was somebody two tables
from me
like somebody [ __ ] you know that
growing up in new york city and north
bergen i never [ __ ] saw someone you
know when i grew up in northbrook and i
saw richard gere before i left new york
i saw richard
gere i saw the [ __ ] good-looking
white kid the irish kid that lived in
the village and he was dating a friend
of mine in fact the husband showed up at
the comedy store and he's friends with
richie and he goes you know my wife and
i go yeah arianna what's her name
because ariana alvarez i go she used to
date in like bro in high school she used
to date
the irish actor
godzilla's
the outside rob lowe no
patrick swayze um
who who else is in the outside you can't
think of one person right now matt
dillon oh matt dillon yeah why saw me
irish kid matt dillon would come over
and take her to a bar right in my
neighborhood and i would go up to the
cop blow and i'd see him up there at
this [ __ ] dive and i wouldn't say two
words i was too embarrassing
i went to ask him the first week i was
there i saw people i don't remember who
and i got picked up hitchhiking
by don henley i got picked up
hitchhiking by john denver i got picked
you know i bumped into these [ __ ]
people you would hitchhike yeah because
they have a hitching they have a
hitching post it's allowed
so right outside the hotel where i got
the quaaludes it was a hitching post
you'd sit there and the car would come
up and go and you go snowmass village
get in how you doing joey eleanor what's
happening what are you doing i'm a
copper-pan snowman oh no [ __ ]
what do you do
right now i'm trying to go to see m.c at
that time my cover was i was going to
colorado mountain college i really was
i would take [ __ ] six credits what
did i know i didn't even have a high
school diploma on paper did you know
that on paper on paper i did not have a
high school diploma i lied in those days
colorado mountain college when's your
graduate you have transfers not really
you could apply to north bergen okay
we'll get them on the phone okay when do
i start class tuesday thank you
and i took the whole time i was there i
took courses at colorado and that in
fact that's how i became an electrician
oh okay i took a couple you could take a
train
i would take like a stupid course and i
would take like a history course i would
take like uh
you know like a business course or
something like a health and exercise and
i would take like a [ __ ] history
class or something there you go
it didn't matter you know me
no i don't know that always kept me
busy legit and with an excuse
to get out and breathe i would get out
and i would go back hitchhike trouble
with the air there because i remember
first i got there
april 30th of 83
and to be honest with you like
at that time it took me maybe four weeks
to acclimate
and three or four days a week guys i
would sleep all [ __ ] day
yeah it was cause it was hard i didn't
realize especially at that altitude i
went right to snowmass it's not like i
went to colorado springs i went to
uh boulder we went right up there in the
first night this sunday
i told somebody recently i think i put
on the podcast i fainted the second day
and asked me smoking a bunk i [ __ ]
went down
i remember people doing the oxygen
during the oh because i was there during
the festival and they'd have them on the
side of the stages for comics so they
would always do that i'm thinking of
taking my wife and my daughter with the
daughter's godfather and his wife he'd
call me nice because he called me the
other day and he goes hey man i got
friday off well there's this place for
sale
no no
he called me last week and he goes hey
man i got friday off
do you want to go to denver to watch
george marsdeval against whatever and i
go you know what man i'm going to shoot
this thing next week if i don't have to
shoot on friday i would think of taking
a late flight friday night right out of
burbank yeah and going over there
there's only two flights direct you take
that late one you gotta go to [ __ ]
utah and san diego no no you don't get
to [ __ ] uh denver till two in the
morning or some [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
miami sound machine is that the computer
do you still have to take that little
commuter
from where into well i guess if you're
going to denver no but aspen
no they go direct now now oh yeah
remember that little [ __ ] play that
plane was aspen airways
and you fly from there to denver and you
gotta land together and then i remember
taking trips to new jersey i'd come back
and by the time you land in denver
there's a foot of snow and that little
plant ain't taking off you have to sit
at the airport all night with a package
and the balls were closed at two
the one that i know i had my coke in the
locker
i had about eight ounces in the yellow
manila envelope in the locker
and every 10 minutes i would go all
right this is the last chunk i'm going
to take out of it
and i would go into the men's bathroom
snored up and go to the bar and drink
and like you know how much money i spent
on quarters putting that [ __ ] coke in
and out of the locker that night
they didn't have me on camera that's the
[ __ ] i think about i thought you were
doing your laundry that's no no no it
was the yellow quarters it was a yellow
manila envelope and the bar was 30 yards
away
and i got to talking to this guy from
l.a i'll never forget that night there's
still nights that i sit like oh my god
how they didn't catch me i pulled an
all-nighter at an airport
and snorted the whole time jesus like a
[ __ ] animal everything tried to jerk
off in the men's bathroom all that type
of sickness that i was going through in
80 [ __ ] it seven all that sickness i
was going through jerking off in
bathrooms and [ __ ]
oh my god i feel like this is like this
is my life kind of
oh yeah just to let you know well
i love it this is why i hate writing
sometimes i'm trying to write because
you can't write real you have to write
real you have to write what's true to
you i i never really did cocaine but i
will tell you this i was when i was with
my first ex-fiance he was doing okay and
i found out i was doing his laundry
naturally and
i found the little vial and i was like
what is this and i like smelled it like
what a [ __ ] idiot
like that's how naive i was i was like
and then i went like that and tasted it
like all of a sudden i'm [ __ ] csi
eleanor and i tasted it my tongue went
numb and when i went in to confront him
i had a completely numb tongue and i'm
screaming like look
at this you know and i'm i'm like i
think my tongue passed away that's how
[ __ ] strong it was why were you
tasting it do you know what tastes like
no no
from the movies i think so i don't know
i thought like it would like tingle or
something like oh yeah you know how look
looking back without the jokes how this
how disappointing was it to see somebody
go from
zero to 60 to zero listen it's a
horrible [ __ ] situation it's not just
somebody when you like for you it's
somebody but for me it was literally the
somebody he was he was the first guy i
truly fell in love with
truly thought i could look at him and
see our kids i could see what they look
like i could see how many there were
all of it and to watch it go like that
and down
never in my life would i
the day i found him in his room and he
was with his uh
buddy i thought was like helping him you
know what i mean and uh he they both
they both just graduated or came out of
uh betty ford and he um they were
shooting up together
i did not
expect that they had just come out of
belly for yeah and the and i had no idea
what happened and
at this point i was like arguing with
him i'm like what is wrong with you and
i'm like trying to wake him up and i'm
like grabbing him i'm like what is the
[ __ ] is going on you know i thought he
was getting healthy and i was coming to
visit and you know like because i still
wanted to be with him i still wanted to
make it work and i was like shaking him
and he wasn't coming out of it and i'm
like what the [ __ ] so i went into the
guy and i was like what did you do what
did you guys do and then when i went he
wouldn't answer me he's like i don't
know i don't know what happened and then
i went back in and i saw his arm and i
was like [ __ ]
so i
realized what they were doing and then i
got a baseball bat and i chased the guy
out i was looking at things on the way
out i was like get the [ __ ] out of here
he went flying and then i
the only thing i could think to do was
to call argus hamilton
and i told him everything that was in
the room every single thing i saw and he
was like you got you got to get out of
there he's gone
and he was right i never really
technically saw him again thank god he's
doing great right now he's doing really
well he has a baby got him got his [ __ ]
together but i mean he went
really down down and it sucks
that's why i was like i don't think he's
the only guy i really want to marry
sorry andrew
it's really weird when you see somebody
[ __ ]
just go down yeah because he had it all
i mean he had it all right it takes
i saw it myself but i saw it a lot in
other people you see you see a million
people go through it
but it's it's it's brutal it's
yeah it took a long time to bounce back
from that
just it started going a little uh crazy
i didn't go crazy i just thought all
right i guess i'm not having kids [ __ ]
it
i i'm i'm [ __ ] grateful everyday i
don't snort that [ __ ] no more no
how [ __ ] lucky am i and it doesn't
live here anymore apparently though he
he would do it recreationally
prior to this
and uh he
never really got addicted and then one
of his clients
brought him pure cut cocaine and once he
tried that that's when the [ __ ] hit the
fan
because he couldn't get
that high
he became chasing the dragon if you will
like after
he was like trying to do anything that
would get him that high but you can't
always get pure cut cocaine no lisa
aren't you lucky you just eat chocolate
and puke from time to time
oh god i'm really lucky i'm i'm lucky
that i just don't know do you still have
the star under your tongue
why not i'm not gonna remember this
night anyways why no
no i'm fine is that why you record this
so that you know what happened on the
night of yeah eventually
like 20 years from now i'll watch this
but um do you never have like sometimes
i have
like my big thing is is fast food and
fat being bad with that
and sometimes when i feel bad or i'm
having a bad day i i go back to that i
cheat on a diet you never have that with
co i i know you haven't relapsed but i'm
sorry i see what you mean i'm saying you
never have any sort of
itch at all
that's great what do you do like what
what is your thing
the first 30 days it was rough
the first 30 to 60 days
it was rough once i got past new year's
eve i'll never forget being in san
francisco with rogan
redband because i was never in new
year's eve snorla
oh that was that's amateur nationalism
yeah all good
i had i i saw something once on new
year's
and i said [ __ ] i'll never get high
again on new year's plus i didn't want
to be high i had this superstition that
maybe this is the year i stopped doing
coke
and i won't be high at midnight
okay i'm saying towards the last couple
years i would get high at 1203
just but as long as i wasn't high at
midnight that's all that mattered to me
that's how [ __ ] [ __ ] and
addiction no you're ways with you you
know but you're absolutely right and uh
no
right there like
it
it took about three months and all of a
sudden i saw something i hadn't seen in
years
i saw a bank deposit flip and it had
money
it's a big deal
like it wasn't 2120 or
it wasn't
or
1853
3041 cents anymore
it was now 318
and i was like that's [ __ ] up yeah
and then you i did the math
and you don't want to know what the
numbers were
the numbers were astronomical absolutely
the numbers were so deep that terry had
to take a loan out for me for 636
dollars a month for six years
that's how it buried what i got i
believe it
and we paid it off in four years
thank god
yeah
but that's how deep it went
but the crazy thing was that wasn't the
first time
yeah like the story i'm telling you
about aspen the first time i left
i left with
some cash because i had julia had rob
from different joints and a block of ash
and [ __ ]
i was i've always been an animal you
know no i get it i love it then the
second time i left
i left with you know
a half ounce of coke
3 000 cash and i owed 70.
like i owed 70. like i owed somebody
like 25 like there was somebody i owed
25 000 oh my god they would call me
every two days and go come on man you
gotta help me out here
you're killing me here type [ __ ]
there were no threats one lady said some
[ __ ] how do you not get threats who are
these people are they commoners like
there were people who had
stumbled in the 80s
people like uh
let me give an example like what i mean
commoners not gangsters not gangsters no
this is let me describe yeah because who
would this be somebody like redman
okay in
1987 a guy like red band can make five
g's a night
selling grams of bloat this was a
village okay this was a little village
it was three miles to go down the hill
and it was i don't know maybe seven
something i may be wrong to go into
aspen okay to hit
old snowmass i don't know how long it is
either but there's nothing in those
snowmans but a gas station at that time
once you got to the village you were in
the village there was the tower
there was another bar up there and there
was maybe three bars up there that were
open and two hotels that had bars you
had five places to go six
there was a mexican place that was very
kinky
and that's where all the drugs were that
was a reputation so that's kid
this kid that was like uh like i just
said to you somebody very commoner
mm-hmm got into helping somebody out
with coke and next to you know
they were from mankato minnesota
and about 30 of them had been there
and a guy and a chick that was not
[ __ ] got involved in the drug trade
and let me tell you something within a
year
they had become a filthy rich they went
from being zero wow to a hundred there
was so much coke up there at the time
and we've discussed the story on the
rogan podcast where people have
contacted me where
in 1985 december something 1985
they blew up a guy with a pipe bomb at
the aspen club
this this club it's like you know a
thousand a week to be a member in that
mm-hmm and he used to always pay people
20 bucks to start his car
the one night he started his car there
was a pipe bomb in there right before
[ __ ] christmas man they weren't
[ __ ] around up there
there was some major league [ __ ] the
people who turned me on to aspen not the
people i went to ask him with
but the people who turned me on to aspen
turned me on to asking because they were
moving blows through aspen
they had a fake carpet place called far
east treasures they had one carpet in
there and it was never opened hard east
treasures yeah i would call it
everything this microphone i would call
it every [ __ ] day where you at answer
the [ __ ] phone you're never open
they're in the furry
[ __ ] history hilarious
but that's that's uh but yeah that's
what i'm saying so you owe these or
whatever you borrow money from these
people i mean i can borrow ten dollars
in my neighborhood without them knocking
them this was the weird thing illinois
in in in may of 1987 i was clean and
sober okay and i got a visit from danny
bianculo who's a member he calls into
the church from time to time
i grew up with the beyonce and he goes
i'm coming up to see you he comes up to
see me goes what's going on cokes
and he whipped out this bag of coke that
was just beautiful it's this it's the
heyday of cocaine
this is the heyday of cocaine it's
crystals it's pink
this is this shit's coming at you your
throat would get numb
you wouldn't get speedy you would get
like [ __ ] after a day or two you
started loosening i mean this [ __ ] was
real yeah
and uh
what the [ __ ] was that
what was the guy's name
bianculo the bianculo kid came out he
shows me this
and he's telling me now i'm buying grams
of coke
and egg balls for 350.
you know
i'm getting railed up there it's good
[ __ ] but
but they wanted 1800 for an ounce
daddy showed up and he goes i give you
this for 800 pounds
i said you know what leave your number
on the table within two weeks i showed
up on that and picked up a [ __ ] uh a
quarter kilo 12 ounces oh my god ninety
eight hundred dollars you know how much
money that 90 hours was mine
zero zero how do you
borrow the whole 9800 chunks
like just but i knew the coke was so
good
that once i come back i charge 1600
and i only take a grandma and put a gram
in
for 1600 this cocaine you'd buy two
ounces right off the bat all i had to do
was come over and give you a blast of
this give me 1600 cash
when do you need it right now so that 3
200 there
by the time i get off the plane i
already have half of it sold which was
you guys money
so you got your money might even that
night wow i might drop half of your
payments off tonight
and then wait till i get more dough the
next day and drop off the other two
payments but that whole 9800 plus the
plane ticket plus the money i had to buy
for the suits
yeah you know goombah you know saying
how to do the hair
yeah i was going home you know what i'm
saying
people say like the hardest thing out
here like you always hear that people
hate self-promotion
and you're selling shares
of cocaine
and i don't understand like how crazy is
it like like
you have no
you have no uh
nervousness or qualms of selling or
people like some people i told them some
people i told and some people i didn't
tell oh my god what are you talking
about i just need the envelope you'll
have this much tomorrow you wouldn't do
that to someone yes i would oh my god
isn't it is that it isn't that like an
accessory to like um and i had a guy
from movies not your business i had a
dude for a video store and his brother i
had these two dudes from a video store
from his brother i had a kid that worked
with a pizza place that wanted to be a
gangster so wait a second i'm italian
what do i got to do if i do this does
that mean i'm a gangster absolutely
this kid was like raised in [ __ ] uh
you know did you tell people
oh no hysterical the poor kid they had a
pizza place the pizza place was hard
and i had this other kid cato that was
my dog in those you
he wasn't chinese his name was keith
corn out of [ __ ] ohio he was my dog
he knew where all of everything was yeah
this was like when i moved to aspen god
when you're a [ __ ] junkie
when you're into drugs you're not going
to meet intelligent people you're not
going to meet bank investors
you meet people the similar type that
you are sure we're all attracted to
everybody i met was not a cocaine head
nose dad the first three or four people
i met with serious marijuana dudes
goddess and i looked at the one dude
when then i go come here for a second i
go okay they'll do me a favor
from now on because kayla would buy weed
every day three times a day okay cato
was a maintenance clerk who made a bunch
a month like in charge of buildings like
a lot of people start as a [ __ ] snow
shoveler but then the next season nobody
comes back right so they get they become
the manager you could be a [ __ ] and be
a manager in two [ __ ] years he was
there for 15 years making eight thousand
a [ __ ] year only in ski season it was
a scan this got a beautiful car because
the business owner could trust him he
wasn't going nowhere he hadn't you know
he had investments in the area
but cato was a professional weed dude
like i was i loved marijuana that was my
number one passion
especially friday nights because i had
to watch usa night flight
there was a show on usa called usa night
flight and from nine through 12 was just
about music
from 12 to three they showed like a
short film and scientist [ __ ] and by
that time i'd do a couple lines just to
keep me awake because the tv was so bad
you're a dork about drugs
you love you love it you're like nerdy
about it bad tv like i know at that time
i watched usa night flight let me watch
usa night flight
usa knight flight was a show that usa
i get it your network put on in the very
beginning called night flight and what
it was was a pop culture show
from nine o'clock at night to six in the
morning what it would cover all night
eleanor what would they talk about a
seven hour show from nine to twelve from
nine to ten they would do an interview
with
batman
jesus
from nine to ten they would do an
interview with pat benatar
and then from 10 to 11
they would show a concert of pat
minotaur oh i like that and then from
11 to 12 they would show her videos
and other assorted videos then at
midnight some pop culture
movie would come on sometimes it would
be the story remains the same
sometimes it would be the new young
movie sometimes it would be pink floyd
live in pompeii there was all these
little movies and then at three
it would be like music news
and movie news this is way before
anybody was doing this [ __ ] no like is
that well it's not before mtv no no this
is
i'm talking when i was doing this this
is 83.
mtv came on the scene september 81.
so usa was 83 at that time in aspen if
you just had a regular tv channel it was
channel two and that was everything they
would show the news and charles bronson
movies
i swear to my mother's grave they would
show the same two movies death wish and
the one about his watermelons when he
[ __ ] they stole his watermelons and
he shoots the [ __ ] up there in
colorado
and i was in i was in heaven me i'm like
look where the [ __ ] did i move to i'm in
i'm living like a doctor here nobody
bothers me nobody knows i'm a [ __ ]
thief
nobody knows nothing about your charlie
brown that's it i got a kid who brings
over reefer sometimes twice a night he
would show up at a bag of the best weed
eleanor
you would ever see and on the way home
every night i would go into the
supermarket and i'd buy like a steak but
i'd steal a salami oscar my salami to
pick pack and i had a lettuce and i'd go
home cook the steak and make a salad
oh yeah i make a salad with the [ __ ]
salami i put salt and pepper and then i
dope it up with a little blue cheese
okay oh jelly in his
tremendous joey's recipe i could dope up
a [ __ ] dead cat if you give me a
minute wait just just a double check the
salad was lettuce and salami that's it
maybe a tomato if i had an extra 52
cents you know what i'm saying and i cut
the tomato nice i put it in there dope
up the you know how good that [ __ ]
blue cheese tastes around that [ __ ]
tomato when you taste it
with a little pepperoni with a little
chunk of blue cheese on the tomato and
you bite into both of them at the same
time to hit you up with mola are you
[ __ ] kidding me or what come on guys
what the [ __ ] are you dealing with some
[ __ ] amateur here i'm trying to drop
the [ __ ] menu of the year on you
[ __ ] how would you go through an
entire book what's that how would you
throw an entire bag of weave in like two
hours in those days that weed would last
me two to three nights
but i would have four or five bags of
weed and i had jimmy
so as soon as i got home at 6 30 i was
now fishing
and then two nights a week weeks i went
to college
so the other five nights i was either
home
or and smoking dope with jimmy but jimmy
had a girlfriend who had herpes
everybody knew she had the herpes she
had given him the herp so i once a month
it was it didn't swell up and [ __ ]
oh my god
did you have your own cops in the in the
apartment oh [ __ ] yeah i could never
lose someone who would hurt people why
yeah don't be mean i'm not it's
controllable it is controllable it's
funny oh my god she had a stinky dog she
had a dog that was a great yellow man
but he wasn't allowed in the building
that would get evicted so he had to live
in the jeep the dog got evicted from the
building they wouldn't let her and she
didn't have no place to live she was
trying to save money to get a job her
name was vicki something i call her
vicky lane louie's lame and [ __ ] i think
she hated me it didn't matter i used to
torment her life
oh my god that's terrible i'm great at
her face
vicky lane you know i think about when
people
have doubts about leaving somewhere that
was a great question you asked before
lee
you know there's people about getting
excited to move out you know there's
people who listen to the podcast and
there's people right now who are like
sitting there going you know i'm putting
away money to move to montana or
california or back to jersey or new york
and you're always a little scared and
these stories i'm telling you right now
about colorado in 83
that was the first time i was ever out
of new york city yeah that was the first
time i was ever not in miami i was in
another state
by myself i had a roommate but he was
struggling just like me it's not like i
couldn't i couldn't be late with the
rent there
do you understand me like
what i'm saying like you're saying take
the chance move out no no no but it was
amazing like
walking home in those days in november
and in colorado if you lived in those
places at night all you smell is wood
burning okay and you can hear it
crackling right and you can hear it and
it's cold but not really and it's real
quiet and serene and i would be walking
in that parking lot like walking and
doing what a 21 year old doing skating
down half of it and i remember going wow
what these [ __ ] are really
missing
and even though i'm by myself look at
what i'm doing by myself i agree i agree
that's the most important thing that
people are always scared of they don't
know if they're gonna that satisfaction
of having that closet with that fan
you're eating what you want you're
driving lyft
yep yeah and you're trying to put it
together just to prove to yourself that
you can and there's one night where
you'll be there with crackers you have
the computer on watching game of thrones
and you'll have crackers and you have a
can of uh sausages and a coke one
and you'll sit there and you'll go how
[ __ ] lucky am i yeah i'm in
sacramento i mean
los angeles living my dream i might be
broke but for tonight
i'm good yeah i'm good i'm not home i'm
out of that bar i'm out of that
environment
i'm out of that that's what that that
part of my life always was i was ashamed
how it ended they caught me robin i
planned the jewelry heist
they already knew i was burglarizing
these places i was in deep they knew
what they didn't know i acted like i
didn't do coke
that was my cover
doesn't isn't that every cokehead's
cover no no no at this time i was doing
that because pretend like they don't do
it this time i was doing it to steal
got it the finger can never be torn to
me why would he steal he don't even do
coke look at the size of him he said he
lifts weights and hits a bag every
[ __ ] day he does push-ups in between
outside like an idiot
i played the pothead
got it you follow me and then i the pot
had never and they would snort coke
around me and then they'd talk and we'd
go back into their house and they played
dodge awesome to come like i would come
out of the back room with a kilo of coke
and i go here we go we got a pigeon
and there we go pilot to bombardier and
i give him like right away with those
guys you just put them on a hook you
just got one guy
eventually gonna throw him in there you
just gotta work him and see what's going
on the movement in the house who his
roommate is i knew the roommate the guy
worked in the [ __ ] golf court
that went away from the daytime and this
guy skied the apartment's wide open
and the coke is in the bed and the
bedroom somewhere or in that closet in
the hallway there and i got five minutes
but there's a [ __ ] sliding window in
the living room so like when i come into
place i'm gonna open up the sliding
window i'm gonna leave it open just so i
have
the option to walk out the sliding
window if they come to the front door
okay so i would always open up my path
out before i even go for the loop i'd go
for the loot
i'd find the loot i'd lock the door how
it was and i go out the back door i look
ba boom when i walk out the back door i
may believe i was looking at birds oh my
god it's a
silver belly blue
chip from kevlar
did you learn that door trick the hard
way like that seems like like something
like you might have to learn when you
like get trapped somewhere i was really
good at it because all the condos were
made the same
from building a to building oh okay they
were all the same cut if i could break
into one door i could break into all of
them my buddy was an engineer and he
made the clips
to bust into all the doors but my cookie
listen i'm not the smartest dude in the
world so one night
there's new people live upstairs and
they're talking about drugs all the time
and i don't really befriend them i just
hear them chatter at parties how much
blow they do so i watch them when they
again i go into the [ __ ] front door
lock the door the lights are out
i go in the back but again it's snowing
us
so i get to the back door and i slide
open the sliding door
and i [ __ ] go to the back and boom
there's the blow i see the lights pull
up
i close the door above them i lock the
front door i go to the [ __ ] back as
i'm running out boom i left the screen
door up the one with the flies so the
flies won't come in and i landed right
in the [ __ ] grass and i just closed
the sliding door
and they were right there
and i [ __ ] ran it wasn't fresh no
thank god that's what saved me yeah it
was old snow so i didn't leave i just
ran i ran into like the water
i ran across and i went to the crestwood
where i used to work and i saw my friend
call and i gave him the coke and i
changed shirts
and then he gave me a ride to my house
like nothing happened
and the next day there was [ __ ] each
other somebody around my house for eight
hours is a blow
that's terrible
did you help him look for it oh yeah you
should have seen me out there putting
out posters and your dog with you it was
[ __ ] crazy
i was 19 years old
doing this kind of [ __ ] jesus christ
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
just making like that's the thing it's
not like you were in jersey where you
had friends and you could come up with
schemes you were out there by yourself
yeah just like oh my god getting stoned
and thinking of weird criminal [ __ ] you
could do okay so now i go back to
[ __ ] new jersey
i end up living in a playground i don't
do blow denver back to jersey i go back
to jersey
i [ __ ] up completely i i live in jersey
till 85 and i moved to boulder i got a
little loop put away but bro i was a
[ __ ] dirty fever
i got 10 g's in the back i got 6 grand
in my pocket
it's a sunday night i'm walking on the
pearl street mall there's one of those
cookie houses where they make this is
paul's cookies they had to let the
window open
it's sunday that's their fault it's
sunday you know what i'm saying there's
money in that hut you're stealing mrs
paul's cookie one of those cookies i
didn't say no names no names [ __ ] oh no
names you understand me i [ __ ] jumped
in there there wasn't a register i just
plugged the register and press open
i was such a bad thief i used to unplug
the register and take it with me because
sometimes i was so [ __ ] i couldn't
even open the [ __ ] register so i
would have to go to the car open up the
back door leave the trunk open and go
out there with the whole register and
take it to go i did not know about the
take at the ghost what are you talking
about
where would you hide the register on
your way out i would [ __ ] put in the
trunk of a car and go step on
when you're running through the mall
with the register in your hand no no i
wouldn't be running to the mall we
registered the business will be locked
it'd be like an independent business i
go in there
you know oh okay i thought you were
ready
they turn the electricity off so you
can't open up the register so you got to
unplug the [ __ ] thing
and pick it up and you got to bring ply
sometimes you got to bring cutters with
you with gloves i always had gloves on
because you might have to cut it because
they they hide the plug underneath like
they build around sure
i must have taken 15 registers in my day
and then
and i knew nothing about it but this
dude named tom panesi got brushes so he
taught me he had a missing eye he was a
westie when i invested the guy used to
get me jobs and i was like 18 to case
joints and he used to tell me how to
steal and [ __ ] he's telling me how to
take care of ingrown toenail and prison
and [ __ ] i mean this dude was the best i
loved thomas you had all the answers how
did you get a job chasing joints
can we talk about that for a second how
do you get what a job
that's a big job that's a big job
yeah
that's a big job i had a dude once a guy
that paid me to just stand by the wall
what do you do i can't join him by the
wall ten bucks an hour just stand there
from six to twelve but you got a
document it's not easy work [ __ ]
hilarious
the guy's name was mr bojie
and he used to hire me like three nights
a week to stand by the brick wall don't
move
i'll bring you a sandwich in two hours
[Music]
i'm surprised you ever left that seems
like you're the perfect gift you used to
tell me one of these days i'm gonna get
you a job 12 15 an hour
sweeping a roof you know what i'm saying
that used to be the job you wanted come
on mr t get me a job sweeping the roof
12 15 and now what do you do you just
sweep all day just sweep the roof every
day eight hours a day just sweep the
same roof it's gonna be all right
it's gonna be all right and then what
and then just watch everything just be
like nobody sweeps the roof it's a
no-show job
that's what it's called the sweeping the
roof i need a job sweeping the roof yeah
eleanor you knew that right yes i did
that's [ __ ] crazy sweeping the roof
yeah i'm sorry that's it
come on lee you've never swept a river i
i thought it was a job where you showed
up and just actually literally swept the
roof so you were getting paid and you
weren't doing anything i mean i should
wait who in that right mind would sweep
a roof unless who in the right mind
would know what a sweep in the roof john
means it's a
you get a no pig
i didn't see this in your in your mouth
your handbook that you gave out when you
saw the memory i didn't have the mafia
handbook that's what it was called a
different kind of mafia wait quick
question when you write your book are
you going to put a chapter in there of
recipes please
no no that's the second book oh you want
to just do a whole thing i got to
support that kid yeah i love that
i want to give a shout out to my main
man water boxer
making a comeback kentucky fried sports
casey mckenzie
candy parker maverick the monster jim
nunya always representing you bad
[ __ ] and his little goomba death
big thornberry
big frog and ryan posh
sterzel you bad [ __ ] uncle joey
loves you don't forget next weekend i'm
at
zany's nashville atlanta come down
because i'm not gonna see you this year
and i probably won't be making it to
charlotte at this point either so if
you're in the local [ __ ] show up
zany's is a good club dwarf is waiting
for me it's all over but the shout and
[ __ ]
what [ __ ]
what [ __ ] sweeping the roof
you sweep the roof
uh that's what the yeah that's the best
job ever no show job do you yo do you
ever have a no-show job
one time carmen balzano got me a no-show
job at horace mann and i'll never forget
like i used to just walk in there and
get a check and go home like he was just
saying did you even move a desk this
week
not really
free country what a great country you
don't even move a desk
nothing you don't even help the channel
he's 150 years old there's no air
conditioning he's 90 and you go home and
play [ __ ] basketball and you got the
audacity to go pick up a check with a
smile this is a good country america
yeah well great cause he used to say
that to me all the time are there people
who do that for like a career i did it
for a song carmen got me a job for a
summer at horace mann sweeping i think i
showed up by three days and i was like
come on guys
you got to be serious let me get how
come everybody has a job and they don't
have to [ __ ] show up
i got to show up now no it's not [ __ ]
fair i'll [ __ ] call the daily news i
call it the cubicles it's not fair that
i have to show up come on
everybody had in north bergen at that
time everybody had a job
for the town and then they had some on
the side that you showed up for an hour
a week
you know what i'm saying and you still
pulled out 20 grand
so nobody really said nothing you know
what i'm saying i only had one
nobody really said nothing
and you got 20 hours you got dental
envision
and everybody had one of those dental
and vision and i was getting eight
dollars an hour at the movie theater i
don't know what i didn't get dental and
vision in mind i was just on a book and
then they at tax time i got the checks
like they would pay the taxes like he
needed me on his books
kind of a thing
yeah no no i always i never went in
there i don't even know where the office
was
i worked for hearts mountain roofing in
high school
i worked for arundo i worked for rental
lumber marine
but it was mass back century and i got a
job at massback century hardware
one of the best jobs i ever had that i
blew
over a piece ass
i couldn't take it i had to go give her
a stab and she wasn't gonna [ __ ] me she
didn't [ __ ] me
she didn't [ __ ] me for four years after
you know what i'm saying absolutely i
told you i totally all the time lee i
was so [ __ ] at that age wait so you
hope you had a job and you he's good
he left him made the shift he's telling
me he left midship to go have sex you're
not saying that right there was no sex i
swear to god there was not even sex
wasn't even in the picture then but you
were trying
i was just trying to uh
making my girlfriend
oh okay how old were you i was
18 going on [ __ ] 92 of course
and before my senior year in high school
somebody said go to tony avenue go to
west side avenue look for jobs there's
always jobs on west side
and i had worked at a hardware store
before so i walked into this place and i
applied
they called me three days later and
asked me if i wanted to like the four to
twelve shift
and i was like absolutely and i did that
and all you gotta do is
pick up chains
yeah and pull orders like that no no
pull orders what you did is after you
did inventory
your first 90 days you did inventory so
you learn where everything is okay so
when the trucks came in the morning you
had to unload them and you would take
them push them in a push cart
and then go to isle 5250 so they wanted
you to learn where everything was first
that was your first 90 days
and then after that they put you to pick
orders
so you drew now you got a car and you
were cool
you got a car
you know how envious i was of those
[ __ ] guys i'm like one day i'm gonna
be one of those guys
i was gonna be one of those guys and
then there was day loaders
that loaded the trucks and then there
was a night loading job
that everybody said was the best job at
the place but nobody wanted
seven to four
every day one day through friday but on
friday you went home with a call today
why so late because there was a half a
truck to load with four guys
but the union would make you go down
there so you would go down there at
seven and put a pipe on a truck
and then you'd have to sweep till the
quarterly and then go
never
in the three months that i worked so
that's what i i got a job there
and i lasted 90 days and also my job
came up to load trucks at night and i
became a union
as soon as i became uni that made me go
on that list
and i was like number three on the list
and number one didn't want the job
he had a girlfriend down and she didn't
want to
and the other guy got married he didn't
want the job
so they came and asked me i was like oh
[ __ ]
i got like a six dollar raise
and fridays i'm off
so i quit school and i could still go
out friday nights at eight o'clock oh so
you're saying i thought you meant you
have to say late eight o'clock in the
morning you used to go
that's how cake this job was lee this is
how we taught uncle joey is
i did this job for like five weeks and i
loved it i loved the thought of
walking in my house at five in the
morning
smoking a [ __ ] joint
i'd make a cheese omelet
i'd flip over the two egg cheese
omelette in those days i'd flip it over
and put two [ __ ] pieces of american
cheese on top
i got like four pieces of wonder bread
toasted with butter nice all right and
then i make a protein shake
in those days and i'd [ __ ] eat the
eat the cheese on me
and drink the protein shake and i'd
smoke another joint
and then i go downstairs put on hbo and
go to sleep till like [ __ ] three in
the afternoon like get up do some drugs
make some calls make some hustling lift
some weights and i go back there at
seven o'clock but i got a call one night
this is big big ass party at thursday
night you gotta be there
what the [ __ ] am i gonna do i can't quit
this [ __ ] gig i just gotta eat who's
that you're in the union i'm in the
union i made it
i could go home and tell my mother like
tony and scarface your son is a success
and bro the party ate me alive
oh i [ __ ] stuck my finger down my
throat and puked
no i puked on my shirt and said i got a
guy called for the manager he wasn't
there so i jumped off the truck and i
ran home like a little [ __ ] that i was
and put on a t-shirt and went to the
party and she wasn't there
she had gone home already she got high
and she couldn't take it so she went
home she was a young little white chick
how bad do you think i felt so i kept
calling they wouldn't answer the phone
so the next day they fired me
it's a month out of christmas i get
[ __ ] fired i got responsibilities i
got a cocaine app but i got a bar bill
you know what i'm saying in those days i
used to hang out at joan mary's
give me a little [ __ ] vodka and just
give lee whatever he's drinking
get pete whatever he's drinking put it
on my tab coke or your dab it's 62
is it friday yet no then what the [ __ ]
keep pouring
you have a weekly tab a weekly sadly and
how high would it get 100 but you got to
make a move how much would you make a
week
100 nothing
i was stealing with three and i was
working at the warehouse
at that time i was probably making a
hundred uh 600
650 a week but when i was working i
wasn't drinking 100 a week in there that
day i was paying cash right but once you
started hustling right you always had a
tab at the ball you had no problem no
credit card no nothing that was a big
thing that was a big thing back there a
tab you had a tab at the grocery store
your mother had a tab at the pizza place
your mother had a tab at the florist
your mother had a tab at the bodega
everybody had a tattoo like when i was
growing up you had a tab at hash ways
yeah miss hash i'm gonna roast beef on
rye potato salad the coke put it on my
tab you got it and you're like
what what a country what were the rules
of the tap like how how when did you
ever pay friday friday
it was weekly definitely sometimes you
could eat something and ask for a 20 and
sign for no
well i never did that old school dog old
school
i would come in
what's your name
eleanor nice elemental lizard hi my name
is joey diaz how you doing yeah big
favor before i left the house
today i didn't take any cash oh do me a
favor give me your bar time for 200.
okay ring me up and give me 200 cash and
keep one video so
okay thank you it's a stolen credit card
we're partners you don't see nothing i
don't see enough what driver's license
do you put on it
d four five six seven eight oh that's a
similar number i've heard that one
before
you follow me
you went out with a yardstick i mean
that was a thousand [ __ ] things you
did as a young kid then
you know there was a thousand ways to
make
if you wanted to go out you always had
lately i need a big favor though what
coco i can't lend you money no
you got 300 quails
you're sitting on them like an [ __ ]
sell them to me what do you want for a
hundred two hundred but i need to get
bro give me the [ __ ] hundred quarters
and i'll give you two and a quarter
tomorrow morning you want two i'll give
you two and a quarter tomorrow you know
how quick you could sell a hundred
crazily how quick in my mother's grave
on mercy you know how long you you could
[ __ ]
two days four hours no at the right bar
four [ __ ] hours how many people
40
i'd have the whole hum i had the whole
place eating gorilla biscuits and i'd
have them calling their friends to come
down to the bar this guy's got the
[ __ ] original deal do they like did
they rarely 30 people passing out bars
no what i would do is she like gorilla
biscuits she knew the [ __ ] rules you
know how she knows what time it is
eleanor's been down the block before oh
no no she's gonna give her from the
block
i'm gonna give eleanor a half a quail
and if i behave myself she might give me
a little nookie cookie you might have a
little good time you know what i'm
saying if i play the cards wrong she
might just go back with that bartender
that she usually likes but she knows i
got a quarter round to blow i got a
couple gorilla biscuits i got a pocket
full of hundreds and you know what she
doesn't care
joey's like
joey's a little fat he might have a
little dick but you know what [ __ ] it i
got [ __ ] by a big dick last weekend
sometimes you got to give the [ __ ] a
breather
oh my
god
you really do you can't get you can't
swallow a big sword every week you gotta
give it so true it's not easy it's not
easy
we're doing the lord's work out there oh
no lee there was tabs at dry cleaners
sure no
cleaners
my mom wouldn't like that my mom didn't
like the tabs but my best friend her mom
no problem anywhere we went we could say
her mom listen man tabs put you together
as long as you didn't abuse them
yeah abs put you together bar tabs
killed me like i think i'm still not
allowed at
gregory's seventh day weekend i like to
tap in there for like 200 and [ __ ]
that's where i was going go give me 20.
that's 40
then they would take a piece of paper
put coco
40
will pay friday and then they put it
involved with the envelope for the night
and they put it on the wall with your
thumbtack with all the other white
papers
and you come in and pay for the [ __ ]
papers there was the that comic that he
was a bad scam artist bad and he come to
me at the comedy store when i was
waiting tables and he'd say run this
card for me he had his nails painted i
don't know if i could say his name i
remember it but i'm afraid to say how
long ago uh like in the early 90s
mid 90s before i got there oh he was you
might have been around like a little
yeah
he
maybe late 90s but he always have his
nails painted you know he's like crazy
guy talk like this right
and you know what it is no oh
anyway so um his name was bob i'll give
you that
and so he would always he would be like
i want to i want to buy drinks but i
need to get some cash back i'm like okay
and then you give me like four credit
cards all of them have female names on
them i'm like dude come on dog killing
me and then he married one of our
managers and i was like dude he's gonna
rob you and she's like i love him though
she had the big titty anyway
but yeah he used to come there oh my god
there you go
i don't know how many more hints but
that was uh a really [ __ ] up time he
was [ __ ]
crazy he would i mean he had cards i was
like dude what are you doing out there
that was the beginning of my end at that
time
but he knew how to get around it yeah
i don't like to say the name yeah he had
to change his name he left he's in
seclusion but he's working as a comic
somewhere
i remember correctly listen he was about
to sign with three yards
but he lost
his [ __ ] mind like people do and then
what happened was
this is one of the best stories you'll
ever hear i just get to the [ __ ]
comedy store i don't know i know jimmy
shooting
i know jimmy schubert i know joe rogan i
know dave tyree and eddie griffin i know
uh
the guy with the things sanchez luke
torres right right to check the puerto
rican check
that had uh whatever his son laura vinca
no the black kid the the kid that's two
comedians the [ __ ] joe torres come on
okay kim tavares i'm sorry i love her
you have these nice [ __ ] people
mm-hmm
what are we talking about
this [ __ ] the scammed the
bob
and
all of a sudden it really became this
drug place do you remember the kid od in
the back on heroin
that was the crew that hung out there
there was a lot i mean okay i got i got
i got made
i got made with larry vizios laravazio
mazios and this chick that was a lesbian
and this other dude and i never saw the
chick that was a lesbian again i never
saw it never do it again okay the only
one that came up from that crop was me
and larry roseanne so you guys got
promoted the same night i mean you got
past past the same night they made us go
upstairs and i worked for enz mitchell
with shane matash in the telemarketing
department upstairs no i remember it
well that's [ __ ] crazy
and i had my own office and i was facing
so this was like
this is 97.98
okay and then this guy bob showed up and
he was very nice and he was very funny
he was good writer he was friends with
carrot top
and uh
he was
you know he was a cordial guy and he'd
invite you to do a blast and and he
reminded me of somebody i did time with
yeah that was a very loyal trusting guy
and i loved him very dearly this guy had
no reason to be my friend
he was a big ass white dude from philly
i never ever forgot him another yeah you
told me about him i'm writing this thing
about guardian angels now these people
are guarding angels i'll never see them
again
you know by doing the show and by doing
comedy i would wish a guy like that
would hit me up on facebook and go did i
do time with you at camp george west in
1987 do you remember me
and tell me something we did i would i
would my heart would break right just to
know that that particular there was like
two or three dudes in there the dude who
gave me the notebook to become a
comedian mm-hmm the librarian the little
nerd who killed his wife and her [ __ ]
mailman boyfriend okay okay i would love
to see him today he's probably still
doing either he got like two thousand
number one yeah
what a [ __ ] shame saying how you
doing buddy i'm doing pretty good this
uh
for some reason i just love when you say
hello luna so the little luminous
they're kicking in front of me
i gotta wake up tomorrow and go through
that rest of the pilot tomorrow we're
going downtown can you talk about how it
went or not yet well i don't know how it
went i mean he likes it so far you know
me dog i hate everything
the last thing i want to do is see
myself so
it's in their hands they sell the show
yeah okay they like the footage from
yesterday
i got my wife in it as my consultant i
had an idea for them today and they
liked it so tomorrow i gotta go to the
flower center and talk to them about uh
she lets mice out she lets cats out at
night at night
to kill the mice what does she think
you know do they kill birds also that
type of stuff
excuse me then from there we're going to
my house
and we're going to shoot me dean doing
the intro
we're going to shoot
my wife talking about the story on a
shoot about me
adopting the cats and [ __ ] you know i
would go home instead of stay out and do
blow and
how they gave me character and a little
bit of meaning and i started realizing
wait a second i could take care of these
[ __ ] cats
i always thought i could take care of a
cat
next you know i'm feeding cats and i got
the little balls and [ __ ] with the
string
and uh you know sometimes you rescue a
cat but sometimes the cat or the animal
that you rescue rescues you brother you
don't even know it that's true you bring
the animal home and you're like jesus
christ i feel a lot better nothing feels
this [ __ ] good so
that's what the pilot is so
we end shooting tomorrow we're gonna do
a podcast scene in here
that's right with my man
[ __ ] boom boom sciatica ready for my
my side card and uh this ain't sad [ __ ]
sucker this this is your on the cuff
card where's my trailer get your hair
and makeup done that's your hair and
makeup done and [ __ ] where's the
paperwork straighten your beard what the
[ __ ]
oh i got him so what are you hearing now
talking man i know you're on the road
with andrew i'm on the road with andrew
we're in vegas uh
next weekend the second super bowl
weekend
uh the second third fourth
and then the
17th
18th 19th on my birthday uh are you the
19th yeah nice i'm 54 on the 19th wow
[ __ ]
the second to the fourth i'm in
nashville i'm wondering how that airport
is going to be sunday morning
going to la saying or whether or not
houston so it has nothing to do with
uncle joey no i'm going to the other
side
uh then i'm doing that kid rock cruise
in april so i'm excited about that going
back for a second time
there are partiers on there boy now what
are the performers
it's mostly uh i don't know who else is
on um this one i have to look it up but
uh the last one the last one was tone
loke
uh he was great we had a [ __ ] blast
but i think this time it's empd is that
high i'm terrible with that um i gotta
look it up it's this phone works but uh
tone low cr kid rock performs
uh they had
steel panther
you know that yeah the guys from vegas
they had uncle cracker they had uh some
really fun uh
it was like a rap band i don't know
where they were from europe they were
great though they were they were all
dressed in adidas suits and they would
do like classics from the 80s and just
like sing over them they were [ __ ]
great like really like a fun
not like a killer band but like a fun
band and then uh yeah it was all bands
and me
so i had a blast how many days are you
out there we're five days
and i have to do three shows 45 minutes
each and uh i'm just looking for the
lineup if i can find it and the last
time you bought the boyfriend that was a
[ __ ] nightmare you said that yeah it
was tough [ __ ] stuff and [ __ ]
this time we have the struts epmd john
stone band he was on last time big rock
show sweet tea trio dj salman
uh dj p and eleanor kerry how many
people on the boat it's [ __ ] packed
five thousand five thousand i think
seven i don't know and it and it's big
it's scary it was the first time i'd
ever been on a ship elevators and
everything elevators everything i didn't
do that i took the stairs i don't [ __ ]
around i'm playing no elevator you ain't
playing
when i got when we got on we we had
stayed in miami because i love miami so
last year we left out of miami so i went
early because i wanted to stay at night
in miami and uh i walked around by
myself i left my boyfriend at the hotel
it was whatever so
hanging out in miami the next day we
went and like in the afternoon well i
didn't know they went the night before
and most people already boarded so i
thought they were getting on the ship
and they were already that [ __ ] up i
was like holy [ __ ] we're just getting
here these people were wasted but that's
because they were already partying while
the ship was docked i mean they just
they spend that kind of money and then
they get on that ship and they just
[ __ ] let loose every woman had their
top off with [ __ ] kid rock stickers
on their nipples it was [ __ ] great
now are your rooms big or everybody says
it's not huge but it's not terrible
it's you know you get a nice room we had
a balcony
so you know you're on the you've got a
nice little balcony
yeah you walk out there sit out there
and hang out and we hung out there a lot
and then we're the artists are a little
bit off from where the other people the
regulars
nobody bothers you really it's pretty
cool you get all these passes too so you
don't have to really hang out you can go
behind backstage and watch the bands
versus like
you know fighting through the crowd to
sit up front kind of a thing and they
come we all support each other's shows
it was it was like dogs
they know people bringing drugs on
that's not my business uh did you see
dogs i mean it's a [ __ ] question
though i did see dogs i did see i
thought you said drugs but yeah i did
see really they got dogs out there well
i think i think you have to go through
customs joey i don't know if you can i
don't know if you could go on a cruise
you know my passport i don't know about
that i don't remember if i saw dogs for
real dogs or is this a code so you you
have to have a passport right for a real
yeah
i had a passport because we went to
jamaica this time we're going out of um
tampa and we're going to the bahamas
and key west
i feel iris
look at that
irish cuban i hope my sister's going to
have kids irish cubans that's crazy
she took a picture last week my wife
sent it to me i almost had a [ __ ]
heart attack you know why you look at
these pictures [ __ ] where the [ __ ]
did time go i know i keep telling my
friend that like you know it's so hard
in the beginning but then it goes so
fast oh my goodness look at her
a little doctor suit on his shirt
oh my and her and the [ __ ] wife
listen
everything's fine in the living room
she's with me tyree's on the couch
terry's on the chair
she's laying between my legs with her
[ __ ] cell phone
and
the cat's next the baby has a cell phone
no she gets terry's cell phone
yeah yeah but now she's punished again
from the cell phone
because every time she gets involved
with the cell phone and the computer she
pees and pants because she gets so
focused on the cell phone she don't i
guess it doesn't she doesn't get it so
my wife is furious tonight so
tonight before i left the [ __ ] house
i'm in there trying to write and put
[ __ ] together
and they have one argument terry what's
the problem she won't eat i said sorry
enough for nothing how many times i
gotta tell you she just ate at school
and she told you when you said dinner
i'm not hungry
she went up there and it was uh salami
with
some [ __ ] vegetables and something
who eats this [ __ ] terry what's wrong
with you i don't say nothing i don't say
nothing because at this point
why style of argument
nobody said [ __ ] yeah my wife will eat
raisins my wife will rape but she'll
raise my wife to death 10 minutes later
let me get raises with yoga let me get
raises yo let me get raised with you
my wife is such a stingy [ __ ] she
actually goes to the cabin and gives her
one box i tell her get she'll come out
daddy can i get a box of rain go ahead
if i stop her and check her she got
three boxes i know that going in you
know what i'm saying but i'm not gonna
accuse her or nothing to bust a bull i
don't even ask her i just hear her run
behind me
that's all you hear
to do
she slams the door she's four
then about 18 minutes later
daddy can i have some you know it's
always something because she don't want
to eat then at six right 6 15 she ain't
hungry she just got home she got the
energy of a [ __ ] savage her thing is
going up not down
absolutely she just got this get back
from school she's just getting back from
school she gets home now it's a
different type of stimulation yeah she
puts the [ __ ] suit on
so today she was uh who the [ __ ] was she
today
today she was a country western thing
she had that pink hat on i asked her
before i leave can i borrow your hat no
daddy
right here it's a [ __ ] comment we're
in the middle of something yeah i'm
watching youtube videos [ __ ] thing no
so that was the beginning
and then i went into office we ate
dinner everybody was excused
my wife let it go and then there was an
argument i don't know what the argument
was about i came out she goes she won't
finish it
i stuck up for mercy you know she don't
want to eat don't eat i go you can't eat
later okay right all right fine go to
bed then i went back to the computer
room about 15 minutes later he yelled
and screamed and yelled on the screen i
just shut the computer like what
happened now she goes she peed her pants
again i got then she got
i said now i gotta i gotta stick with my
wife you know what i'm saying sure i
know she can't have the [ __ ] phone
she threw another fit
i took a shot one left i got no time to
argue with women who was saying i got a
wife i got a podcast i don't know i'm
going to say that arguably too crazy
[ __ ] it you said them against each other
and then you leave
[Music]
in fact they put her in the top class
but this is when she gets on that phone
it stimulates her a different way
well sure people like get they get into
she forgets and i ask it three times you
got to pee we did the same thing to my
nephew
no daddy you got a pain not that all
right she [ __ ] pete i mean so my wife
bans it for two days my wife's [ __ ]
hitler good for her white throws in that
back room and she's done you know what
i'm saying you've got to try this little
daylight i go back there because i got a
back door to her room i'm like a [ __ ]
uh you know sneaks in so i sneak in i
give her a hug i tell her i love it i
bolt out of there before she starts
making noises and [ __ ]
i tell her she has a teepee i'm pitting
him again
i threaten her every night i'm gonna
sleep with a teepee today no you're not
daddy
it's for my [ __ ] whatever she's got
the ugliest teddy bear in there there's
some [ __ ] thing from frozen
oh
yeah she's got olaf in there
all of us in there i'll move him over
let me sleep with him
no daddy go out daddy please leave daddy
you can go now daddy cause i'll torture
i'm just leaving the [ __ ] teepee
she loves that [ __ ] teepee with all
her heart i love that it's a little
indian [ __ ] hysterical when you have
children and what you learned from them
what we forget
i'm sure we did the same maybe we didn't
have as much but we did the same kind of
[ __ ]
a tp would be like building a fort for
us we had that triple bunk bed
so we would put the sheets let me tell
you what i was doing this for best
my mom had this bar
and behind when you walked in there was
a panel wall
that you could tip over if you laid on
it
but nobody ever laid on it it was like
this wall right here
without the wall in the back i tell you
when you come in don't touch that wall
because the whole thing came backwards
so it was it was shaped
like one of these things like a
rectangle so the bar and right here
there was a door
to where the pool hall was and where the
pool club was in my mom's place but
right in this area here there was a
curtain
but behind that curtain there were beer
bottles a backstack of beer bottles and
there was maybe 50
cases that were empty
a [ __ ] alcohol like beer bottles that
were empty i would take all those boxes
and line them up at the age of four
right like two walls and i would put
them up like
five feet even though i was like four
foot one
i put them up to like five feet and then
i'd run at them and knock them down
my mother would lose her [ __ ] [ __ ]
like what the [ __ ] are you doing
like this is what i was doing to my
mother at the bar people would be
drinking with the balls and here
and it was me running into a [ __ ]
case of [ __ ] empty beer bottles jesus
that must have been so loud
jesus christ i feel bad for my mother
give me those [ __ ] things i'm happy
you came out you got any dates on them
hey just the uh yeah the
vegas with dice i'm trying if i get a
philly date or more god of day you're
coming with me oh i would love it and
[ __ ] like that it's a new year
[ __ ]
it's a new year
all right all i have to say to you is
one thing
everybody needs work right now things
are going on things are tough
but opportunities are opening up for
people and weird [ __ ] ways you know
i knew nothing about this lee's the
young guy lee would tell me yeah i took
a
this the other dad took that the other
day then he came in here one day and he
told me did the acid that night
and then he [ __ ] uh
took a lift and he told me what lift was
and uh what'd you think lee i loved it
that it it's
it's a great service i i feel like
they're a little bit nicer they they i
actually went through their driver
training at one point
that they they have a real emphasis on
uh getting to know the the people you're
riding with it was just a nice
and and
and this person this specific driver was
just really cool he had a nice car he
had lights in it no they have all the
cars you like all the packages
they do have uh they do lyft does have
uh premium packages so if you have a
nicer car and you sign up to drive they
give you a higher rate okay so yes so
yeah so you they have all that it's uh
and then they have um a thing called
live line which is really cool where if
you're going
they'll stop and pick someone else up
along the way and you guys it's a
cheaper fare okay oh yeah so it's uh
they have a bunch of different options i
took them that time you turned me on to
them and they were great i i really had
a great time the guy was great he had
waters in the car
that's the best it was a nice car no no
it was a great experience
so if you're in between jobs and you're
looking to earn some extra money right
you're going back to school yourself to
get another degree or maybe your first
one
maybe you're writing the great american
novel and you're looking for some
inspiration
or you're seeking
alternate funding for a new startup it's
not a bad idea to go to lyft
there are other ways to re you know ride
sharing apps out there but lyft treats
their drivers right it's a flexible way
to make some extra money anytime from
nearly anywhere all you need is a car
lyft drivers can make up to 35 an hour
and getting started is just a tap away
you could drive mornings nights weekends
just flip into driver mode and start
making money plus
lyft drivers can earn tips
right through the at those add up fast
you understand me and you don't have to
wait for days or weeks to get paid you
can cash out instantly once you've made
fifty dollars all right fifty dollars
thanks to express pay now driving with
lyft is super flexible okay
listen guys this is the way to go it
allows you to keep 100 of your tips and
there's always and they're always there
when you need extra cash this is one of
the best jobs going what are you doing
you're paying a high nut for your car
you're sitting home watching tv at night
take two rides what do you care do me a
favor sign up today go to lyft.com
joey and right now lyft has a special
offer
for our listeners you'll get 500 new
driver bonus after you complete 100
rides within 30 days
go to lyft.com
joey today so you can start making extra
money and get your 500
new
driver bonus limited time only
restrictions apply all right what do you
think you're dealing with joey bananas
or what number two one of my best ever
you know what
a friend of mine called me the other day
and he said he was very happy that i
recommended this to him
because he asked me one time that he
heard about all these type of things
lee was on it lee blue apron
i love it it's it's a great service it
it it teaches people to cook
it's healthy
and it's easy
there's no there's no complaints and
it's perfectly measured so there's never
any waste did you uh what were some of
your favorite recipes you told me about
oh my god there's a spicy pomodoro pasta
that i i it's just amazingly it taught
me how to make a tomato sauce which was
great i loved the uh the there was a
chicken but the thing that i loved is
that it taught me how to make mashed
potatoes i've never made that before in
my life
not once before in my life listen to me
look at me what's up i'm one of the
dumbest people you know even i was
making mashed potatoes like 12 you [ __ ]
same potatoes
milk a little dash of sour cream and
some [ __ ] butter with some salt and
pepper
and whip that [ __ ] up with a fork
then turn it into a spoon see spanish
style what are you nuts or what lisa yet
you should be shot and hung but i'm
happy blue apron taught you how to make
mashed potatoes now not all ingredients
are created equal fresh high quality
ingredients
make a real difference so it's important
you know where your food
comes from right less than ten dollars
per person blue apron delivers seasonal
recipes along with proportion
ingredients to make delicious
home-cooked meals choose from a variety
of new recipes each week or let blue
apron's culinary team surprise you can
you imagine coming home and they're
sending you like a lobster tartare what
are you nuts or what recipes are not
repeated within a year so you'll never
get bored customize your recipes each
week based on your preferences blue
apron has several delivery options so
you can choose what fits your needs and
there's no weekly commitment
so you only get deliveries when you want
them each meal comes with a step by step
easy to follow recipe card we're ready
for this one pre
proportioned ingredients and can be
prepared in 40 minutes or less wow you
cook everything you go in the shower you
wash your monkey you come back out you
stir it and within 30 minutes you're
eating like a savage you understand me
check out this week's menu all right
cheesy chicken
and black bean enchiladas what are you
nuts or what cream shrimp spaghettini
that's the that's the the two-person
menu the family menu
ready for this mix mushrooms and potato
pizza with fontina cheese and spinach
can you imagine learning how to make
that at home blackened cajun catfish
with sweet potato all this stuff you can
learn from blue apron so do me a favor
all right right now you get three three
meals i'm gonna give you three meals for
free with free shipping by going to
blueapron.com
joey listen it's a new year you got new
options give it a try you'll love how
good it feels and taste and you'll
create incredible home-cooked meals with
blue aprons so don't wait that's
blueapron.com
joey all right listen
give blue apron a shot columbus did
that's blue apron.com
slash joey
columbus oh my god
what's a good week lisa i love you to
death look at you look what are you
doing this weekend surprise me this
weekend what am i doing what is the
torture of death what are you doing this
week you're taking a balloon to [ __ ]
sprints oh
no it it's paul's birthday on sunday i'm
not sure what we're doing yet
you better get on it uh well we might i
don't know let's go see the harlem
globetrotters oh they're here
it's on my birthday oh really sunday's
at the staples [ __ ] yeah why not
i don't know she's gonna like it i would
hate for her to get sick on the way down
there so sometimes you and she got sick
again in the uh but not good in the car
what about the climbing would you get
sick on the train i'm not taking my
childhood no [ __ ] lemons no trash
this is
helps a lot with the car or mints any
kind of mints helps with the nausea
because i used to get carsick
i'll clean it up each [ __ ] with your
fingers and [ __ ]
you got to come do the comedy story
podcast for us
for two [ __ ] years no it's not two
years only two months you know what man
from time to time i love you
and i can't tell you how very proud
a lot of people
you know even that story about the
fiance oh that could have broken most
people a lot of people from there you
just go to drink and a year later your
mother sends you 200 to take a greyhound
no you're going home sperm is drinking
dripping out of your spoons your
asshole's all busted you know i'm saying
you were in love you were saying
he ran up your credit card he crashed
your car
you know yeah yeah you could you're sold
your car bob baker
no that's what made me think of bringing
up the store podcast because we could
talk about the conversation store
stories so there was exactly so many
funnies
so that's something that's bad enough
about bakers up there yeah and every
night you go up to bob and go bob let me
get a tasty give me a taste and go bob
what's the story show me your gram
brother listen
give me 10 minutes the mexican's gonna
show up and i'll take care you know and
he always showed up i remember him too
but then then we would go to rent a
hotel room some nights
me him shoes a bunch of us yeah we'll go
to that sunset in chip in 20 hours and
go into those rooms and snort
get a bottle from the store and then
stop and get other bottles
and then what the [ __ ] happened then all
of a sudden one day this guy
he used to be a [ __ ] degenerate fiend
but he sold his comedy club like
somebody came and bought his laptop oh
do you remember him in 1998
lee this guy came out here with a
suitcase with like 300 000 cash
and checked into a hotel on sunset it
was in his room
and i would go to his room and snort
coke with him i never got to the money
i always stole an eight ball i stole
more eight balls from anybody he put
them all on the count i always took one
in between my fingers and closed my hand
would you keep it in like the hotel safe
no
the money was somewhere in that [ __ ]
hotel room
and if i tell you something lisa
tell me
he left here when that suitcase was
empty
i believe and it took him four months
he spent 300 large in four months on the
sunset strip
i believe it he lived in [ __ ] in a
hotel
he ate steaks
yeah he even bought a kilo to try to
sell coke and make money to recoup his
profit
he went under he lost [ __ ] money
he lost [ __ ] money because he was out
every night
bob baker him we were out every [ __ ]
night i know i remember it horrible
horrible time horrible time horrible
time
and i used to live right there with the
kid bobby kelly
so i would just walk from that hotel to
kelly's house and i remember taking a
girl from the hotel with no blow i was
playing i'm like come on let's go back
i took it to the building to the
stairway
who the [ __ ] do you think you are you
fat bastard you check me and she just
ran away i go [ __ ] i go back to my
house and go to sleep what do i get she
walked me halfway to the door you know
oh i can't
it's a different time when they're
walking you to the door
amazing
i'm happy that you guys tuned in i love
that you came on the show tonight
night you're a bad [ __ ] i'm
really proud of you as a woman as a
female comic did you march on sunday i
did not march on saturday good but you
stuck to your craft yeah and you
believed in you and the belief that most
women [ __ ] tap out by now yeah find
the [ __ ] guy have a kid and say [ __ ]
i did comedy for a while i knew
everybody yeah good but
it's tough to stick with and that's
where you get my respect that's why
you're on the show and i know i love you
all around though you're one of my
favorite people in l.a lisa got
everything solid over there
you're all [ __ ] up which is good
there's a point in the podcast we're
just seeing colors good
sponsors let me tell you something next
week we have a great guest on monday i
think next wednesday february 1st is
when when lee and i test that acid it's
been fermenting now
oh they said to live for 14 days
it's [ __ ] granulating the sugar looks
tremendous the sugar cubes are you
excited giving it the enough oxygen it's
dry see here's the thing i i like it
it's fun but he tortures me for about
three weeks now and he gets my because
he doesn't know what i'm giving him i'm
taking him to the next level so just
give it to me now he's just gonna black
out and see [ __ ] stars for a little
while and he's going to go on an acid
trip like he's going to see himself in
the desert with a cat chasing them and
[ __ ] sounds terrifying he's going to
wake up sweating like a pig
listen to the [ __ ] do it what is this
peer pressure
absolutely you know i torment him
what am i gonna do what do you think i
call him absolutely listen i call him
with the acid calls three weeks before i
drop it off
so he's
we're going to do it here and then we're
going to go out you always said you
wanted to go out let's go out let's take
a couple lifts
and walk around town and tape it we'll
hire a lift for the night perfect i'll
make something like that
let's do it you know we don't play games
here i love you [ __ ]
see you monday night 8pm same bat time
same back channel follow eleanor hun
uh twitter uh facebook all that stuff
yeah
i have a website a website yeah eleanor
jaycarrigan follow her go see it dot com
she's the last real [ __ ] deal
these women i bring on the show are
[ __ ] savages they all could have been
vietnam vets that's the type of heart
they have give them the respect they
deserve lee
kick that [ __ ] mule [ __ ] i love
you see you guys monday or if not i'll
see you in nashville next thursday night
stay black [ __ ]
you know what you're hilarious hey man
i'm just trying to [ __ ] get this
party started
[Music]
wow
now
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
i